[Music]
ah
jim shark are having one of their
biggest sales of the year
right now if you want to get up to 50
off on your gym way
click the link in the description below
but be quick because things are going
fast
and now it's time for the true jordy
podcast
when i go back nowadays and i think
about these uh these things that i've
been through in life
like imagine being born into just where
your parents are
struggling i mean struggling there's no
jobs to where it's just like
how do we eat tomorrow you know dealing
with the circumstance that we were
dealing with in nigeria yes they weren't
the worst
but my dad saw a better life he had
ambition and he was able to act on that
to where now
we are able to do bigger and better
a things performance for the challenger
so far complete control by usman right
now
[Applause]
it's over it's over for a long time the
goal is i want to be the champion i want
to be the best
yeah everyone trains but these guys
don't understand what i put myself to i
go through
hell when i cross into the cave i'm no
longer a kamara usman the dad
who's silly with his daughter i am the
nigerian nightmare and once i was
already
there you gotta kill me if you not if
you didn't come here to kill me
it's gonna be a long night less than
four minutes now to go it has been all
camaro
tonight that jab is like a right hand
your dad started up his ambulance
company but ultimately
it led to him being arrested i think the
hardest part for me was
trying to imagine how he felt but i knew
who my dad was
i knew that i had that that loved me
cared about me but through that
he was able to see the strength of his
family
to where we had to pick up the pieces we
had to work
from home i never i didn't think of his
career path before he went in
by the champion he goes in and he had to
witness
all of this while he was
[Music]
and i'm the champion of the world
this is a [__] pleasure i'm delighted
to
be joined on the trujori podcast
by in my opinion the greatest fighter on
the planet right now
um this is the number one pound for
pound and
thank you very much for joining us
kamaru thank you thank you that means a
lot to me
it's always extremely humbling just to
hear that
from someone because at the end of the
day
you know we all just want to be loved
and that makes me
that makes me feel feel so humble
i wondered what you'd think about me
saying that actually because
uh i know in the mma world it's a it's a
really
it's strange because it's a very
masculine sport but uh
people can get quite uh feminine with
their emotions especially in the uh
in the comments but you know we do we do
want to be loved and it is important but
i
i guess is that part of what you're
striving for is to be remembered that
way as number one
um yeah there's a there's a fine line
there's a fine line between um
how we're we're uh remember i think it's
not it's not necessarily
whether we like to be hated or we like
to be loved
it's just we like to be as human beings
i think
we want to be acknowledged from what
we've done
because nobody just i i at least not
that i know of
just walks around and says oh i'm just
doing all this i don't care if anybody
knows i don't care if anyone sees it
i don't care if it affects or if it
touches anybody
i don't think nobody does anything
hoping that whatever they do doesn't
affect it doesn't touch
doesn't it's not appreciated it's not
liked or hated or
i don't think people work like that as
human beings the things that we do
we want them to be you know we
want them to be acknowledged to a
certain point to a certain degree
whether you love it or whether you hate
it i just want you to acknowledge that
i've done something
you know it's like think about it it's
like when you open the door for someone
and the lady walks through or the guy
walks through and they don't
they just walk through it's like at
least i would like a nod or something
like
yeah you know i went out of my way to
help
you i grew up idolizing joe rogan though
and like
he's kind of why i started podcasting as
with a lot of podcasters
and i always looked at him and thought
how are you so like
you just he's he's the king of this
world and yet he never
strives to demand acknowledgement
whereas me
i'm not that kind of guy i want to hear
yeah you're the best
i need that and on the way up actually
one of the things i
really like about you uh as a as a
personality as well
especially as you started letting that
come through more
was that sort of unquenchable thirst
for success i i remember watching i'm
jumping ahead but [__] it
the the burns win and and
and after you won and and this was like
a few title defenses in
and this is usually where we see ufc
fighters looking a little comfortable
looking like i've reached the top of the
mountain
you had this look on your face and this
expression
like how dare you think you can beat me
how dare you and that was uh it stuck
with me in my head because
you know i was a conor mcgregor farm boy
for a long time
but the one thing that i was very aware
of is once he won that title
it was job done in his eyes whereas for
you
it was only the beginning and
is that accurate that's very very
accurate um
you know to touch on that guilt the
burns fight yeah that's
exactly how i felt i was i was burning
on the inside
the whole training camp leading up to
this fight
because how dare you say that how dare
you feel the ss
it's not just a competitor a different
competitor
uh as an opposition but it's it's a
competitor that has seen me
do this these guys don't and these guys
don't really
they yeah everyone trains but these guys
don't understand what i put myself to i
go to hell sometimes i'm more beat up
before i even get in there than i
actually take damage in the fights
i would say most cases um i i put myself
through everything before i get into
that
that cage and so in that fight he should
know that because he trained with me for
a long time he knew how hard i trained
for these five
so for him to say that i just felt like
how dare you so when i
put it when i went out there and i
wanted to really show him that i'm
levels above that was this
whole feeling towards it and even in
this last one
with with my fiddle the same thing the
first fight
the reason it was close is because i
took the fight on six days notice i had
a shattered nose in two different places
going into the fire
i couldn't walk all of the training camp
because i had a bad
bad bunion and um
and i still went in there and won the
fight and then for him to just
say all the things that he was saying oh
this it was close because of that
i'm gonna do this and do that i still
had that trip on my shoulder like how
dare you think you can
how dare you and so that's why that
i needed to do that to him in that fight
for him to understand that
and um you know now touching on the
conor mcgregor aspect
and a lot of people a lot of people get
to this point
because for for a long time the goal is
i want to be the champion i want to be
the best
and so they work work work work hard and
then they get there and then it's like
all right i've done it
and in his case he's a little different
than most because
not only did he get there he got there
and got
more money than he ever thought was
possible that changes everybody
i'm not gonna lie like it changed money
has changed me
how you know it has i'm not gonna lie
i'm 100 honest with it money has changed
me yeah
when i didn't have money i had to eat
the spaghettis and ramen noodles
you know that that was just there
because that's all i could afford i can
afford the steak and the lobster now
i want the steak of the lobster you know
but
it changes mentally what about mentally
mentally because you know the extremes
of life as i've done a bit of research
on your life
and and you know i i personally come
from a working class background but even
even compared to what you went through
it was it was really eye-opening
uh how have you changed uh i've changed
because uh i'm changing the aspect of
that
i understand things now i understand why
i went through certain things you know
when you're growing up and you're going
through life
you can only comprehend the situations
that you're in
so if times are tough today
that's all you can you understand you're
you know and we see a lot of
a lot of these nowadays where kids are
committing suicide they're they're
ending their lives because they feel
like it's just so much pressure it's
just so much things that i'm going
through right now and i can't get out of
this
they don't understand that this tomorrow
there's another day coming
and another day coming and only until
you experience tomorrow
can you look back and say man yesterday
prepared me to be able to handle
what's what i'm going through right now
and that's in that that's that season of
life that i'm in right now
is every thing that i've gone through in
life has prepared me
to when i'm faced with a difficult
situation in there
i know how to navigate through because i
know that it's not the worst
because when i was in those situations
back then i thought this
this was the worst thing that i could
ever happen to and now i understand that
there's always there's tomorrow you know
you have to make sure you make it to
tomorrow and when you make it to
tomorrow you've gone through yesterday
so i i love that you brought that up by
the way the mental health side
i personally have spoken a lot about
mental health on my
uh podcast in suicidal thoughts and
stuff and
and it's so great to hear a champion
who's been through those
say you know to to a lot of the young
people out there
you know i felt that i felt terrible but
you know that was what created the
person that you are and and just hanging
on
you know made those bad experiences turn
um turn you mentally strong enough to
get through
pretty much anything and i do think
mental strength when i look at your
reign and and everything that's happened
to you you know i look at the way you
throw punches and i look at the way you
wrestle and i look at the way you throw
kicks in
a lot of the time it's hard to
distinguish between
you and some of the other fighters just
how you've gotten to where you are you
know because
with certain fighters in the past it's
very obvious what one thing
did it for them but with you obviously
you're a very skilled fighter but
i feel like it's the mental side that
has the edge for you
above above even the strength and
everything else that you have
yes i'll tell you the secret that's
absolutely my my number one
strength over everybody is knowing that
mentally
i i this you're not gonna beat me
and if you you can't beat me there at
the end of the day
um there was this big quote to saying
before you when you're training for
preparing for a competition you know as
something as physically demanding as
ours
preparing it's about 90 physical
and then when you actually get to the
competition becomes about 90
mental and about 10 physical and the
reason that is is
we're both gonna prepare ourselves
physically to get out there and compete
but once you get in there now you have
to compete with this because we're both
physically fit why is it that one guy
wins and we're both
same skill level the same you know
fitness level
but one guy still wins is because
mentally
i'm there i'm mentally able and and and
you look at the way that i fight a lot
of people uh
say oh man he's not a fast puncher he's
not the best
boxer in there or the best kickboxer
or or the best jiu jitsu grappler in
there
you know it might not be the best but
when it comes to mixing it all together
mentally being able to understand and
withstand what's going on
i am the best and that's one thing that
i have over these guys i think it was uh
who was a dan hardy dan hardy uh
journalists out in the uk
um a couple of times he would do a
breakdown and says that i'm not
you know i'm not excellent at any one
thing
that i'm about if you compare them to
cars i'm going at about
70 you know 70 percent the whole way
yeah i am some of these guys come out
100 percent
you can't stay at percent for uh forever
yeah gilbert was a hundred percent early
on
early on yeah yes
canelo alvarez actually you really
remind me of him
when i when i watch you i think canelo's
like you like
he he lets the other guy work really
hard to look good
early and you're like okay now i'm gonna
take over
like it's similar yeah and i i think
it's uh
and i attested to my coach now trevor
whitman is we know how to build a fight
you know and while the fight is taking
place we know how to
to get into the fight and and really
break down
our opponents and that's one thing that
canelo does very very well
as he knows how to take his time round
one round two
round three round four the guy still
looks good now especially in his last
fight with billy those saunders it
still looks good looked good for round
one two three four five
and then it it's like they hit this wall
and i'm still going same pace i'm still
going
and they're just like why is this guy
still coming why is he why isn't this
guy tired yet
because we know how to build into a
fight and build into a fight and we just
get better and better
and these guys get weaker and weaker and
i think that is my biggest strength in
these fights to where
i think i'm so far ahead of all these
guys when the chaos
approaches you are very calm and i love
the fact that
um i i kept i kept writing that down as
i was watching all your fights before
this
and the irony of um you know colby
having the nickname chaos when you are
the calm in the chaos that is exactly
what you are
and you are the antidote for that reason
i think but um
just going back to the state of mind and
the mental strength that you have
one of the other things i picked up is
when you take a shot
and i'm not just talking about having a
chin i'm talking about the decision that
comes in your head at that very moment
which
you know 99 fighters out of 100 go
i'm gonna back up now when when you get
clipped
you go forward and that's a real unusual
thing but i don't mean recklessly
you keep your head up and and you keep
your hands up and
and you're calm but that is the
composure
uh very very rare like
i'm that's what elite level fighters
have and i just wondered
mentally where that where that does come
from
that's a that's a great question um it's
something that i picked up early on
i learned that early i've been dropped
one time one time my career
practice competition i've been dropped
one time
it was why one of my teammates uh ufc
fighter fellow ufc fighter lightweight
actually uh michael johnson and
and it was a second year i believe when
i started uh
mma competing and i was sparring with
him and he was getting ready for a fight
he was already in the ufc
and he taught me a very very valuable
lesson
and as human beings when
when we feel pain and we feel certain
things what do we do we tried to run
away from it we tried to mask the pain
we tried to hide from the pain and
and they just kind of translated over to
fighting
as as we were sparring he was landing
shots and he was kicking me in certain
places and i
i was feeling the pain i was starting to
feel it and what i wanted to do is i
wanted to pull out
i would be exchanging punches and i
would want to get away from it because
he's hurt a little more
and i kept trying to pull my head out
and get away
and he clipped me dropped me and
after that i had a long conversation
with my coach and
and he said have you tried because i
used to always be afraid i was
afraid of it because everything hurt
because have you tried actually
walking into the fire i'm like why
what's the
point of that it's like sometimes you
have to walk into the fire
and you realize it's really not as hot
as you think it is
and i've thought about it and i'm like
okay
okay i'm gonna have to try that and then
i would get into kind of a fire fight
there will be throwing punches throwing
punches but i would walk in
you come in psychologically when two
guys
mano imano were exchanging punches
you're exchanging punches with this man
i
want you to let me know that my punches
are hurting that my punches are
affecting you
my punches are doing something to you
psychologically that you don't want to
be in this fight anymore
now when you don't back up and you don't
let me know that then you don't show me
that so when i hit you you step
forward into the fire even more
that is just disrespect to me and they
let me know
that my punches don't do enough to you
to hurt you or to make you back down
from me
and so that's just the mental
superiority that i think that i show
these guys because
yes everybody hits hard i understand
that but i'm willing to die
for and that's just not a level that
most people are willing to go to
so when a guy really shows you that
it's like oh well i really didn't think
we were gonna have to die today i just
thought we were gonna compete i've only
seen like two guys you fought who have
even
tried to to walk forward the rest
they didn't even try yeah i mean a lot
of
fighters they showed they have i mean
very very
skilled fighters everyone they're very
skilled they've worked on this skill
very very much
but having the skills you wanted but
then having the mindset to go along with
the skills
that's a whole nother different animal
and that's just
not something that i think a lot of
these guys have um
i i i did once i started researching you
more and
and what your life was like growing up i
thought
this must be something to do with his
upbringing and
and the way the culture is in nigeria
and and
your dad having that impact on your life
uh am i right and thinking that
yeah yeah absolutely um you know now
that i
when i go back nowadays and i think
about these uh these things that i've
been through in life
is um i wouldn't say they're the worst
things to go through in life
absolutely not you know they're people
that go through harder situations than i
went through
but they were just the right things to
prepare me for
what i deal with now um you know having
to walk
far to school having to walk far with my
grandmother to
fetch water out of the river to where we
got to bring it back now we gotta
you know boil that water make sure you
kill all the parasites that are in the
water
so you have water to eat drink and
shower and cook
people don't really comprehend that and
now that i'm in a state that i'm like
wow
i really went through all of that to get
to the point where i am now to where
i'm gonna point now to where i have
water filters in my house
you know and and so to go through that
to get to where i am i truly appreciate
it i do not take it for granted
and i understand that there's still more
to go in order for me to
to completely finish my time here on
earth
i must it must be the best way to live
life though surely if
if we were given a choice um
before we start this journey and and
god said it was for example you can be
rich from day one and always be rich or
you can be poor and always be poor or
or you could do like one than the other
i'd definitely rather start
not like understanding what the value of
everything is and then end up at the top
um because you really do appreciate it
and uh
tell me what nigeria was like because
obviously i've never been me and
it's fascinating to me to know what that
place was like for you
it's it's different because it's just
such a wide range
of of individuals i i and i still
personally can't comprehend every aspect
of it
like imagine being born into just
where your parents are struggling i mean
struggling there's no jobs
so you you have to somehow figure out
how i'm going to make
money make a living to be able to not
only
feed my wife but feed my children
as well and you're born into that
to where there's no you you're not
there's the schooling is not there
to where it's okay i can just go get
educated and then get a job
it's not there yeah imagine being born
into that to where it's just like
how do we eat tomorrow like
most people can't comprehend that and
then there's the levels to where it's
okay we can eat but we're still
struggling heavy
and this is the small jobs that we can
get
okay and then and but you're still
making life
you know life still continues then
there's the next level where
it's okay we went to school we're
teachers and we're professors where we
teach and we do get a salary but
sometimes the salaries don't come
we're still struggling there's different
levels to where it's now you're at the
top you're born rich and then you you
know your family do have money which is
a very very small percentage
and dealing with that as well because
there's such a difference in the classes
to where you might not necessarily
understand what
those guys in the village go through and
so it's just such a wide range of people
and and even myself i can't comprehend
it we're growing up
you know some of the things that we went
through it was some of the hardest for
me
you know because we farmed right and and
and most wouldn't understand that being
in the hot sun
in a farm farming and harvesting
you know plants uh you know corn
and and things like that it's you know
most will never understand it but these
are some of the things that i went
through in life to where
you know it makes you it just it builds
this character inside you that you can
never
pay for no amount of money can ever pay
for that
and your dad was in the army am i right
and saying that yeah
yes my dad was in an army and so being
in the army there he moved around a lot
of course
and so he's moving around a lot so i
didn't really get to see my dad
until the first time i remember actually
physically seeing my dabs i probably was
four years old and so
imagine that of course i heard about
this man all the time and my mom tells
me all these stories about this man
and and it's great and i i love my dad
though i'd never seen my dad
okay so he was like a superhero to you
but like almost
half fictional here of course so
you know you know your dad because your
mother of course my mom pours into it
lets you know what your dad's doing
where your dad is at what is
you know why he's gone so you know all
these things okay that's daddy we love
daddy
and then to physically see him at
certain times like oh that's him
okay you know so it's like the love has
been built the stage is set
he's just waiting for him to show up and
perform wow
and then he shows up and it's like oh
yeah that's it fall in line
and you know just going through that and
then
all through life in the different stages
of life that i went through with my
father
it's all just it ties in together
to where it puts me in the space who are
mentally i
i'm able to deal with a lot of things
but um you know i'm sure
you know i can't go inside my mind to
really dissect each and every thing but
i'm sure there's
there's great parts and i'm sure there's
not so great parts in there as well
at that time it was sort of an
old-school situation where mother looked
after the kids and she was
raising the crops and he was out in the
army and when he did come home
it felt like i'm kind of feeling like
there's this larger-than-life character
who walked through the door and
because he was in the army and the
nigerian army as well i imagine they're
pretty they're bad [__]
like were you a bit like a little bit
scared of him or was he soft and gentle
or
was he disciplining you or was that
mother's job
oh no he's he's admitted he was an army
guy he's a military guy so
you know just like you would expect a
major in the army to
to be that's how he was um
but it was it was almost the right thing
that i needed
i think you know because
would i have turned out the same way i
turned out if he was completely
a marshmallow which is you know you not
you don't know
i can't i can't i can't speculate on
that
but as for the life that i live now
and that i live i think it was the right
thing for me because it got me to this
point still
so but um yeah he was uh he was a he was
a
you know military guy you know i don't
think uh my dad ever told me he loved me
until like
21 20 21
yeah something like that i got it and
but it's it's not that i didn't know
that he loved me
it's just he wasn't soft to where it's
like oh i love you like i am with my
daughter now
i'll tell my daughter i love her every
night before she goes to bed yeah i've
seen
it's very yeah and so it's
it's different it's crazy how i am a
parent now even though i'm still very
i'm still stern to a certain degree but
there's just a difference and um i'm not
just sudden relationship's a little
different as well isn't it like
especially
he's trying to make you into a man he's
trying to let you know the stance
absolutely yeah he's thinking long term
like
i can't show this kid weakness i need to
let him know i'm the boss around here
sort of thing
oh yeah he definitely did that he
definitely
what about school what was that like in
nigeria can you remember
yes absolutely school was um the school
was great and the thing is you the the
way it's set up the school system is so
we become like there's so many brilliant
kids
in in nigeria so many brilliant kids
because the school system is so tough
you know it's when i was growing up
teachers were allowed to
whip you in school and so when you say
whip do you mean like what with
like go to the back the fields and pick
the switch that i'm going to whip you
with in the front of the classroom
in front of the classroom okay so
think about a test we have a test okay
and you failed the test because you got
four wrong
this was you had to go find the switch
bring it to the class
in front of the class to where i'm going
to get whipped
where how by how many uh questions i
missed
on the exam and so this is i would have
i would have studied hard pretty much
yes exactly
exactly so this was that was the
standard everyone studied so that was
the
that was the school system so you get
all these brilliant kids
that go through the school system and
they get out now the problem is you get
out but where's the jobs
okay there's no jobs and so it's
you know it's just kind of a tough
situation to be in but
you know growing up that was the school
system that i was in um
of course if replaying it in my mind
being in that situation would that be
where i wanted to be
absolutely not but i cherish it and i
appreciate it because it made me
who i am today i i wonder uh because
obviously you're in america now and
similar to the uk
there's probably a lot of kids who are
floundering
especially i feel like young men that i
grew up with anyway who didn't have
father figures personally my dad was in
prison
when i was growing up with my teenagers
and stuff like that and when you haven't
got that
that person to answer to
and the school are soft because they
can't discipline kids the way they used
to so kids don't really fear anything
i wonder how you see the difference and
and if you think the world's gone a bit
too soft now and it needs more of that
or whether or not you think it's a good
thing that it's gotten soft
it's a difference i would say is
different
um i'm i'm not really i'm not really god
so i can't really say oh it's good or
it's better or to worse
i can't really say that but based on my
experience
which way would i like it i understand
that it takes a village to really raise
a
especially a young man it takes a villa
to raise a child
but especially a young man because you
know a lot
is dependent upon us young man because
we have to be able to protect life we
have to be able to protect our mothers
protect our sisters protect our
daughters
so they can continue the cycle and give
life
and if the men are too soft to where
they can't protect
the mothers protect our sisters protect
our women
then the life cycle starts to diminish
and that's how it is in mind
and so yes it's it's definitely gotten
softer
i remember exactly what you just said
if you would study hard if you knew that
if i failed this test or if i got this
that this would happen this consequence
would happen so i had to study hard
but now you take that away now you're a
child growing up you just want to do
childish things because you're a child
that's what you want to do
and now there's no there's no really
governance
on why oh you should do this
or the consequences can happen if you
don't do this so of course you're going
to do childish things you don't care
about
doing that if you don't want to do it
you don't have to do it
so now but you're not seeing the
consequence of what's going to happen
eventually because now you're not going
to be able to earn a living
you're not going to be able to get to a
point where you protect your mothers it
protects your daughters protect your
sisters
protect your women to where now the life
cycle starts to slowly diminish
and and i think absolutely it's gotten
softer
but life has changed though
kids don't necessarily deal with kids
aren't dealing with the same situations
that we were dealing with
back in the day back in the day if you
had a problem with another kid
another bully or something you had to
meet them after school and you just
you had to fight it out with your hand
now kids have got all these different
weapons they've got all these different
tools they know where you are
when you are they can talk to each other
online and there's just so many more
things that these children are dealing
with
psychologically to where it's definitely
changed the game
for all of us but if i could take all
that away
and have the kids still deal with what
we dealt with
absolutely i would definitely do that
because i see where it's got it got me
absolutely and when you talk about the
role of
of young men as well in your upbringing
i i feel like there's so many young men
just
lost right now and they
they have no purpose they feel no pride
they don't feel good about themselves
because they are floundering because no
one did give them
harsh guidance but but guidance
nonetheless harsh guidance better than
no guidance in my opinion
and like i get in you know in in the uk
and america
we're fortunate that women don't
necessarily need protection in that way
but it still would be nice to have that
ingrained in men
to feel that responsibility and to
um take pride in being the protector and
being the provider still even if that
person doesn't need it and
i feel like i i definitely have that
luckily thanks to my mother
but um it's it's dying and masculinity
generally is being looked upon as
as a as a negative thing by some people
but but that
uh the way you described that i was like
yeah i i think that is such a good thing
to have a system that works in that way
absolutely and and when i when i say
protect
um you know a lot of i don't want people
to take it in the sense that
oh we're back in the medieval times to
where it's just free for all people are
just killing each other
no that's not true but part of this is
part of what you get
when there's no governance of what's
going on
because now if i'm these young men
and these young men and women aren't
able to go to school
to earn an education to when they can
get jobs to where they can earn a living
for themselves
they know okay so if you don't do that
and there's no one to tell you to do
that
then you're gonna come to a certain
point in life because life doesn't stop
you're gonna age you're gonna get to a
point where now you're
an adult and there's no way for you to
eat
tomorrow so what are you gonna do i need
to eat because if i don't eat i'm gonna
die so i'm gonna go find a way to get it
so now they have to potentially rob
steal
and do whatever they have to do in order
to get it because they don't have the
education to get the jobs so
by that who are they going to rob steele
and kill potentially to get it
individuals so as young men
then if you're not taught to be able to
protect your mothers
protect your sister protect your
daughters protect your women
then it just becomes this cycle to where
it's just free for all to where
in turn turns into the medieval times
so i'm not necessarily speaking all
women need protection from that because
yes we're fortunate we
don't need protection well men can walk
the streets men can walk the streets
that's fine but it's just that teaching
that responsibility
to men and knowing in that instance
if something does happen yeah what my
role is is is that responsibility
and not just as far as protecting but as
far as
helping you know as a man i i'm
working hard to try to alleviate the
stress that my mother might have
that my daughter might have that my
father might have
you know teaching that sense of pride
that sense of responsibility is to where
now
as you mentioned a lot of men young men
are lost because back in the day
think about it your father your father's
last name meant something
and his father's last name meant
something so it was prideful for you
to be the best that you can be because
you had to carry on that lineage
yeah and so now when they just don't
care then it's uh
you know that's it that bothers me a bit
that really pisses me off like the last
name thing
there's a lot of people who don't like
that doesn't mean anything now i think
that should mean something
you know absolutely it should it should
mean something because um
for you to really work your life's work
and then you
put it in you poured because that's the
cycle of life
you work you work and you put it into
making other people
and your family better and you leave
that for them you leave that legacy for
them
and for them to just uh waste it off and
diminish it and not
care about it that that's that there's
something wrong with that
you know they should be able to continue
that cycle because that's what makes the
world a better place
dude that's that's that's [__] smart
i love listening to you
bro i really i i agree with you on a lot
of what you're saying and having those
those old-fashioned principles that have
really left us
and i think it's a it's a bad thing in
in modern day society like there's so
many great things about
yes we have filters in our houses and
all of that good stuff and food's easy
to come by over here but
that is that is one of the downsides is
it's just
and part of me thinks the system is
almost i don't want to sound like a
conspiracy theorist but like
i feel like the power that the people
have through commute through small
communities and caring about their
families
and that unity that you get in the you
know the passing down of names
it's being destroyed and i i feel like
it's
it's only beneficial to the people who
would rather divide us than
see us um yeah together no i
you you're absolutely right and um you
know just to touch on it really quick
um i remember you know when i was just
being a young man
being a knucklehead and you're doing
certain things that you know
are not the right things to do but i'm
gonna do them anyway because i'm a young
man and that's what young men do
you know my father is disciplining me
and telling me that this is not what we
do
but of course i'm gonna try it i'm a
young man i wanna learn i wanna know it
for myself
yeah so you do it and now my father has
to discipline me
and how i remember and when you speak
about the system being designed a
certain way i remember when
my father disciplined me and i got a
whopping and
um and i remember thinking to my father
i'm gonna call the police because
they're gonna take you to jail because
you gave me a weapon and i know this
system
you can't just whip me if you do that
they're going to take you to jail
because you're trying to teach me the
consequences
of my action and and i remember him
call them and i remember the first time
it happened
i accidentally caught just just thinking
i was gonna be you know
trying to scare him i accidentally
called and i hung up really fast
and they show they showed up anyways
so they show up knock on the door
of course my father answers i'm inside
i'm scared
i'm just scared right now and i'm inside
they call and they come anyways
and so my father opens the door my
father steps outside
speaks with him steps back inside
and oh god says there's people outside
they want to talk to you
i'm scared she's shitless i go
outside and there's two officers
and the two officers have a conversation
with me oh god
that do you understand what you do when
you call us
because you did something wrong and
you're being disciplined you call
us for something that was not an
emergency somebody else could have
needed our help
and you pulled us away from that and
those officers basically let my father
know that
it's okay for you to discipline your
child that that's fine
do that so i felt like i got no help
if it was possible yes now i felt like i
just made things
worse for myself oh no and i remember
now i had to go inside close the door
and now i have to deal with my father
and uh your dad's like doing that
snitches get stitches boy
yeah and it's a it's one of those
situations to where i realized and the
officers were like
yeah that's he needs to discipline you
you're a young man who
didn't listen and now you have to deal
with those consequences
now flip this script to now how it is
nowadays to where it's not like that
you call the officers yeah they show up
they're taking your parents to jail
yeah and that's that's what i mean by
the system
is changed big time and it's designed
now
to where it's like i can't even
discipline
or give them the consequences for for
their actions anymore
so i i completely agree in that sense
that it has changed yes we're dealing
with different circumstances at
different times now but
you know the core values should not
change
yeah i i get why you know unfortunately
some parents uh
you know do need to be arrested
sometimes
but there's a big difference between
abuse and discipline and
we should have common sense enough to
realize the difference between the two
but going back to your time in nigeria
can you remember
did you have any like fights when you
were a kid can you remember what that
was like and
how it was yes um i have two brothers i
have an older brother
cass and i have a younger brother
muhammad um
so we were all about two years apart
and so it was it was the best growing up
with my siblings because
you didn't fight one of us we were all
young
so if you fought one we're a tight close
family unit so you fought one you had to
fight all three
and that's how it was when we were
growing up and so you don't just fight
one of us
if you had a problem with one of us you
had a problem with all of us
and so yes we got in a couple of we got
in a couple of fights going up but
but that that was just that you know you
had to deal with all three brothers if
you dealt with one
so back then even you you didn't shy
away from a physical confrontation
[Music]
i don't like it but i understand that
as a human it's just a human emotion
you know it doesn't matter who it is a
wife and a husband
uh two uh sisters brothers
it's gonna happen you know you're gonna
have a
a fight's gonna happen at some point you
know
now it doesn't have to be physical but a
fight's gonna happen you're gonna have a
disagreement and so
yeah i i realized that to where
of course i didn't like it i still don't
like it i you know
i still don't like people's minds away
i've just i've just announced
people because a lot of different people
watch this podcast and some people might
not be fight fans but it's like
i've just called you the best fighter in
the world and you're like i don't like
it
i don't think that's crazy i truly i
truly
don't like it okay but i understand what
i have to do
you know so yeah and that was the thing
under you know when i even when i was
young i understood that
yes of course i i don't like
confrontation like that
but i also understand that it's
necessary sometimes
but i don't necessarily love
confrontations to where a lot of people
might think so because i am a fighter
yeah you're a very peaceful guy when you
talk you're you're super chill
you don't have the aura of someone who's
trying to prove anything to anyone or
hyper aggressive
you're looking i don't i don't yeah i'm
very low key and i don't i don't need to
you know when it's time to go when it's
time to take care of business i let that
the action yeah i know that um
so then you you came to america is it
texas you moved to
yeah we moved to arlington texas what
what was that like for such a young kid
going through
a major culture change
it was it was big it was big because and
what made it even bigger is
now i'm growing up in nigeria to where
you know the weather is hot
and rainy that's it and
now you get to arlington texas
the first day and this was the first
time it snowed in
i think maybe in the last decade almost
the day that we land it's cold freezing
cold
and it's snowing first time in my life
i've ever seen snow
it's the first day i land in america
and so i'm asking what is this white
stuff
and it's all over the ground and it's
making the cars go
slow and they're you know sliding
everywhere and it's
it was such a humongous shock for me but
you know that's the beautiful thing
about being a kid is you adapt so
quickly
and you uh you just you adapt and you
just roll with the changes
and your dad was the one who um the goal
was a better life for you guys
so he um he became a pharmacist when he
came over yeah
yeah yeah and that's that ties into
taking pride in who you are as a man and
and your
family and what you provide for them is
he truly wanted a better life for us so
you know dealing with the circumstances
that we were dealing with in nigeria yes
they weren't the worst
but my dad saw a better life
he had ambition and he was able to act
on that
and elevate us and immigrate us to the
to the america to where now we are able
to
do bigger and better things than would
have been presented to us
and afforded to us in nigeria to where
now i'm in a position that i'm in and
and
looking back all i have is to thank him
for giving me the opportunity
for being able to to exercise it and get
to this level
yeah when i was doing my research that
was the thing that really came across
i was thinking like the age he was the
risk that was
you know an unknown place a country that
you guys didn't know
and he he he bet on himself and i think
when people do that i have
nothing but respect for it because it
takes balls
courage and um talent as well this guy
must
be a bit of a multi-talented type of
character
to ma to pull that off and to make a
success out of the move the way
he did yeah and and
i still i'm i'm so proud of him for for
even being able to
because that's scary just even thinking
about that yeah it's scary
i'm gonna immigrate to a new country
join the military in the new country
and not only join the military i'm gonna
go to school
yes there's a bit of a language barrier
yes we speak english but it's a bit of a
language barrier
to where i'm gonna go to school and
actually become a professional
a pharmacist in that country and be able
to earn a living and a better life for
my family
and so it's it's amazing it's just you
know it takes
more than just balls it's ambition to
the most high
so yeah i'm extremely thankful for my
dad for taking those chances
and what was it when you went to the new
school like being the nigerian kid
kids are cruel kids are very cruel and
um
yeah it's um it was tough because yes of
course
it's a language barrier because even in
nigeria we speak
english english like when you want to
put something in the trunk you you put
it in the boot
of the car all right you know and and
and then
we say trash can here but it's it's a
dustbin and and certain things
so that's that's the english that we
speak the way you come to america and
things are different and kids are cruel
so kids
laugh at you for speaking differently
laugh at you for not understanding
the terms of the way that they are
saying certain things
and so i got in a bit of trouble a
couple of times because you want to fit
in with the kids
you want to fit in and so when these
kids tell you hey
say this to the teacher call this
teacher this this word
it means yeah you like them or it means
this and you don't know it and you do it
and now you end up in the principal's
office
and they're calling your parents your
african parents
that this is what you just done and you
you said in school it's
uh it was challenging as a kid because
there
are many times where you cry about
certain things because you don't
understand them
but getting over it and being able to
experience those things just
it makes you strong to where you can
deal with way much more
in the future and when did you realize
you had like athletic ability
was that around that time when you went
to american high school and stuff
uh yes i would say in high school this
wasn't
this wasn't natural this was they just
come natural
oh really it was a lot of work of course
we're naturally
uh gifted to i can
run and jump i wasn't the fastest and i
didn't jump the highest
but i had some ability
who could just turn inside anything yeah
it um i was i would say i was about
average
i think the biggest thing that pulled me
away from everybody
else was my uh my mind
and my ability to work out work
everybody
i used to hear that term all the time oh
yeah outwork these guys outwork these
guys but i never knew what it meant
until um it clicked for me
i think in high school when i realized
i started later i was competing in
wrestling
but i started later than in all these
guys
and these guys knew all the moves they
they knew how to
to train and knew how to do all these
things and i didn't know that
and so i thought to myself
how can i close the gap on these guys
okay during the summers these guys don't
do anything they just hang out because
they
they know to this certain point so you
know what in the summer
i'm doing this every day so i'm doing it
every day i'm
running i'm doing other things now i'm
starting to watch
what the best that do this what they do
okay i'm gonna try to do that
and so i closed the gap so fast on all
these guys
because i was willing to work overtime
to why they were willing to just finish
and go home
but i was still working and i think that
was the biggest thing that
closed the gap on everyone to where they
would come back the next year and say
wow that's a different guy than i felt
last year
he's not the same and and that's what
let me know that hey this is what you
this is how you do it
i'm a big believer that like those high
achievers in all sports
they're the ones who spend the most time
thinking about
it and obsessing and care and they care
they really care so to know that you
spent that summer
even back when you were a teenager
thinking and con
yeah where all them were just you know
enjoying life it it shows that that was
in you
even then um what did your parents think
about you wrestling because i'm guessing
that's not in nigeria no it wasn't um
they didn't know for a long time oh wow
i hit it um in texas if
american football and and basketball was
two sports that the main sports that
if you were gonna do sports this is
things that you did
and um
i remember i i was doing american
football and i told my father and they
were they were okay with
said all right that's something for you
to do
besides facing your studies so you can
do that
as long as your studies are okay you can
play american football
we've never heard of the wrestling the
wrestling that we heard of was
the entertainment the wwe
and then of course we watched it on on
television
and so i remember i had mentioned
something one time to my father about
wrestling and he's like no
we don't want to you know you to be hit
with the chair we don't want you to get
hurt
and things like that and that's
what i thought of it and that's what i
said i'm like okay
they're not gonna understand this and
there's no way they're gonna let me
do this so if i told my african very
african military dad that i wanted to do
this and he said no guess what it's all
gone
it's done i can't do it so
i just pretty much my my ninth grade
first year in high school i told him i
was
uh i played football and i did but
halfway through
i i stopped playing football and i
switched over to wrestling
just trying it out and it was the most
difficult thing that i've ever done in
my life
but for some reason i kept showing up
to where yeah most
most football players because we get a
big group of football players after the
season that goes into wrestling and
tries wrestling
but it's let's say the first day 50
football players go into the wrestling
practice
the second day 25 of them will show up
the third day maybe 15 of them will show
up right
the fourth week maybe five of them will
show up
but for some reason i kept coming i kept
showing up and i kept going and i kept
going and i kept going
then one day i hit a move
i i did some type of move that we had
been training and drilling
and i did it correctly and it worked and
then i remember i was walking home that
day
and in my mind all i could think of was
i just applied myself to something
and i learned it
that's one of the best feelings in the
world
is that i took the time i stayed there i
learned it i used it and it actually
worked
i'm coming back
that was it for me yeah that's the drug
isn't it that's that achievement that's
that thing
that's that like and i don't think it's
a coincidence at all that
the hardest thing you've ever done was
like an addiction
like you know and that reward that you
kept getting from that you know the
average people
can't do that and there's something that
yes
because i i do a bit of boxing training
i have a similar feeling when you pull
something off you're like oh yeah
like there's nothing quite like that in
this world
and obviously you you stuck with it
um you around this time
if it's all right to talk about this um
your dad's started up his ambulance
company
and um that was
a huge thing for him but ultimately um
through other people getting involved it
led to him being arrested
and from looking into your story
what an emotional time that must have
been
is there any i don't want to pry too
much because i can imagine it's a very
emotional thing but
can you give us any information on what
that was like going through
that and how he ended up being locked up
like that
um it was tough but you know like i
like i mentioned certain things happen
in life and you don't know how they
affect you
until you actually go through it and you
don't know the the purposes of them
and this was one of those situations
my dad had done such a good job of
working so hard and being ambitious
and and letting that guide him through
elevated himself and us
through life and to the point where
of course he'd come here he worked hard
went to school
and then became a pharmacist and now
he's you know
working but he still had ambition you
still wanted more
for your family to where now you wanted
to open your own company and you
worked hard and somehow achieved that
just the
the the brain power that it takes to be
able to understand how to get a company
up and running
is is is monumental and for him to
study that and get to the point to where
he actually did that
you know it was amazing and so now
that's running and
okay things are great now you're
elevating it seems like you're going
climbing the ladder as a human being
especially as a man that's the american
dream
that's the dream absolutely climbing the
ladder
and now the only logical steps is how do
i continue to climb this ladder
okay well we need to i need i have
opportunities to acquire different
businesses
at different companies to grow my
company
so it was almost to the point where he
kind of
got big to the point where now you let
your company go on autopilot
because you understand the people that
you've hired that
you know these people promise you that
they know how to do this job because
they come from this background they've
come from
different companies that do this so you
trust
them absolutely as long as you guys can
continue to elevate this company and
make us money that's what we do all
right so now you have those people in
place to where now you feel like okay
now i have more time to do my day-to-day
with my family so i don't have to be in
the office as much
i don't have to oversee things as much i
don't have to watch things as much
and everything is fine until you realize
it's not fine
that these people weren't doing things
the appropriate way the right way
and now because of course you are the
owner of the company
they're gonna you're the one that's
gonna be held responsible
and he kind of fell into that and uh it
was tough
it was tough for him you know to know
that
you know i have nothing to do with this
but because i am the owner of the
company and i trusted these people to
do a good job for me now i'm roped into
it
and so um i i can't really ima i can't
even imagine
how tough it must have been for him
mentally to be sitting there knowing
that
i didn't i shouldn't be here but
you know that's just kind of how life is
and
but through that he was able to see the
strength of his family
he was able to see the strength of of
his wife
you know now you leave your wife who for
the last three years you've
you know you've been able to have just
be in the home
and not have to work now she has to go
back to work and find a way
to find something that's gonna
make a living for her while i'm off at
school
now how do i not quit school and come
home and try to find a regular job to be
able to help provide for her
how does my brother not do that and my
younger brother not do that
and my sister being at home so i think
it gave him a chance to be able to sit
down and really
empower his family to where we had to
pick up the pieces we had to work
we had to find a way to get through to
where i had to finish school
my brother my oldest brother had to
finish school now he's a doctor in
pharmacy
to where my younger brother had to you
know go through school
you know and all of these things were
able to happen while he was away
to where i was able to stumble into this
career path
and really apply myself and learn
and build to the point where i am now
you know
i never i didn't think of this career
path before he went in
he goes in and he had to witness all of
this while he was in there
to me becoming the champion and then him
coming out
and i'm the champion of the world
amazing
that it's it's um yeah it's
i think a movie is going to be made of
this one day and i
i honestly i can't wait to watch it and
i can't wait to see
how you know these professional actors
really
portray this because it's really a story
and i'm sure there's a lot of kids and a
lot of families that have battled
something similar to this
you know it's just a human thing to do
to have something that people can relate
to and um
this is is one of those that i look back
on and i'm just like
i'm just blessed and i'm thankful that i
i can be that example
for someone yeah i really felt for your
dad when i was
i was reading up on that you know like
um he did
so much good uh getting you guys into
such a great position
in america and it felt like some
snakes and and ladders game you know you
finally got to the top and then
right the way back to the start it felt
like again but like you say you guys um
because you all have that mental
strength i'm assuming not just yourself
but the family
you were able to stay as a unit and he
it seemed like he even from jail
you know was able to have input into the
family and still be
there to a degree which that you know
wasn't like
oh i'm not your dad anymore i'm locked
up i'll never you know i'll see you in
10 years it was
he was still very much important to you
guys um
yes yeah it was that strong foundation
that you build
um and he did that because
like as i mentioned i didn't physically
see my dad until i was four years old
but i knew who my dad was i knew that i
had a dad that loved me cared about me
through my mother i knew all of this so
it was like
this tape the stage was set and he just
had to step right in
and so having that being the foundation
already
you know i didn't have to physically see
my dad every day to understand that my
dad was there
and to understand that the hole that he
kind of had and the presence in the
family
so of course a lot of things still ran
through him and even
me making the career change you know i
still
i had to go and see him and show me this
is what i'm considering doing you know
of course as a young man at that point i
knew i was going to give this a shot but
this would have been a lot difficult
had he not given his blessing to do it
and so yeah it's just keeping him in the
loop and making sure that he continued
to have that
that uh impact in the family that he did
from start
it was um it was just a blessing i i'm
well the only word that sums it up for
me is that i am i'm blessed to be in
this position
it feels like you're really at peace
with everything now that it's sort of
and how could you not be you mean you're
champion of the world and things have
worked out well for you and
luckily but um just going back to going
to visit him
um obviously you would visit him and
talk to him about some of the life
decisions like your career path
but um how old were you when he was
first
put in jail i think i was um 20
i want to say 20.
no way that was uh yeah i was about
20 20 years i was about to turn 20. okay
okay so can you remember um
the first time you went to visit him
what what that was like because i
imagine that must be awful
um and for people like myself like i
mean
obviously i'm one of the unusual ones
who knows what it's like to have a
father in jail but a lot of people
won't really comprehend what it's like
to not be able to have that
hog or that connection
yeah it was um it was tough
because um
mentally i try to prepare for for it
so you you envision and you you think of
all the certain things
that could um that could happen and and
how you would feel
so i already tried to prepare my mind to
feel a certain way
and then once i got through it um
i don't even think i completely
necessarily remembered it until i was
walking away
wow and when i was walking aways when i
kind of
started to feel the emotions of it like
i'm leaving him there he doesn't get to
come home with me
and and now i think the hardest part for
me was
trying to imagine how he felt
because your family just came and saw
you but now your family's going home
and he had to stay there and not see
them tonight not touch them
or kiss them good night i think that was
probably the hardest part for me
is is understanding that do you think
you're
kind of built that way mentally in terms
of um
you seem to be very good at envisaging a
situation and
and almost processing the ins and outs
of it before it occurs
so that the impact on you personally is
is limited
yeah i think that's just kind of
how my mind is worked is is i'm trying i
always try to put myself
in someone's shoes and i always try to
see it from that aspect
from their angle to make uh the best
decision and
and my mom used to always joke about
this all the time and she used to always
say oh there's three sides to a story
which is true there's your side there's
their side then there's of course
there's
the actual story as it unfolded because
everyone's seen it from a different
point of view so
you know me always trying to put myself
in someone's shoes
gives me a better understanding of how
to comprehend and how to move about a
certain situation
do you apply that in fighting as in your
opponent like
how how they would fight you how you
would fight you if you were them sort of
thing
absolutely absolutely that's one of the
biggest things is
how would i attack me if i was me
and if i was there and um
and i see it all the time and and i'm
just like
i know i know what i think my weaknesses
are
but you're fighting the mind
so when i'm fighting their mind it's
they have to show me how strong their
mind is
and if they can't do that you know
they don't have a chance you're like a
cerebral fighter
you you really do think differently to
other guys
you like some people look across the
street you look across the street
round the corner and down the street
again like you really are thinking ahead
i i truly am i truly am that that's a
very good way to put it because it's
i i'm truly thinking okay how does this
affect me and
or how does this affect them how does
what they're doing
how does me reacting to what they're
doing affect them
and um that's the game that i'm playing
and
and you'll see me if you really look at
my fight and you see me break down
certain things especially in the title
fight me
winning the title for the first time
that fight i would say
i was the most prepared for ever because
i was
a couple of years prepared for that
fight already
so when that fight when i signed that i
got the fight
i knew in my mind i was going to be
world champion
he didn't know that but i knew i was
going to be the world champion yeah
because i had prepared for this fight
three years ago
every time i saw this guy which i i
liked the guy
i respected him but every time i saw him
i just
knew i was going to be this guy
and you will see in a fight when you
break down the fight i do certain things
i do little things in a fight that they
don't realize i'm doing
but i know what it's doing to them and i
know what it's going to do to them over
time
and i'm doing it and i'm doing it i'm
doing it and i continue to do these
things and you just see them do this you
see them come down and you see me go up
and uh and that's i don't think they
realize it but even in fights now
there's certain things that i do guys
don't realize that i'm doing and why i'm
doing that
especially in this last one oh yeah if
you really if people
really go back and watch the fight the
same thing that happened in the first
round
happened in the second round the same
way it started it's the same way that
that fight finished
it's like i'm playing a record over and
over and they're doing the exact same
thing over and over
but i'm adjusting to it each and every
time
and and this this last one that's the
story of it
i put it away i just i wanted to make it
short because i wanted to get out of it
quickly
it was an afternoon you proved the point
and i
definitely want to get on to that fight
because i feel like
you know it's scary that you're still
improving that is
a real scary thought um but uh let's go
to the start
sort of thing or kind of the start you
you you won a wrestling championship
and you were you know uh best in in the
us
um what was what was that feeling like
and how did how did that go
it was um tying into what i said earlier
um
when you learn something that's the
addictive feeling about it why you keep
coming back
wow i learned this it worked okay i'm
gonna come back i'm gonna try to learn
something else
and that caught me to where when i
realized it tied into without me
realizing that
in order for me yeah i'm learning things
but these guys have already learned all
these things
years ago when they were little so how
do i close the gap on these guys
oh i have to work overtime in these guys
i got to work when they're not working
so i start working like that and now i'm
closing the gap on these guys
well how do i i'm there now i'm able to
compete with these guys
how do i beat these guys how do i start
winning the championships
and in high school that was my goal i
wanted to be a state champion
so bad i wanted it i could taste it
and it didn't happen
i felt that setback and it just it
ate me up so bad on the inside to where
no i have to continue i'm not giving up
on this until i
feel what it is to be the champion so i
wanted to go to college
to feel what it was to be the champion
because now in college it wasn't just
state champion it was now the national
championship
and it seemed far away to be able to
grasp
but that was the goal i shoot for that
i'm it's not
okay i am i want to just win a couple of
matches i want to be the national
champion this is the highest accolade
you can get there
i want that so of course with the skills
that i have applied
learning that new things and knowing
that i have to outwork these guys
i use that same recipe now i'm in
college
and i'm working and i'm working and a
big thing too
that i find motivation in where people
don't see that i find motivation
and one of the biggest motivating thing
for me was
that first year when we get to college
that our coaches did this exercise to
where
they wanted us to write down our goals
and
we write down our goals for the year and
we had to say them to the whole team
in a team meeting and
you see guys some of the guys would get
up and say yes i want to be the starter
yes i want to win 10 matches this year
some guys say yes i want to be an
all-american
this year and me i'm the freshman i'm
the new guy
and i get up in front of the whole team
and and i said i want to be a national
champion
and i'm look i'm i'm standing up and i'm
looking at the room
and i'm seeing some of the guys look at
each other like
[Music]
this who's this
and i can't tell you what that did to my
mind
[Music]
to see that guy who doesn't know me
doesn't know my work ethic doesn't know
how my mind works
instantly say to someone else that i
can't
be a national champion i'm crazy for
thinking that i can do it
it just it lit a fire inside me that was
like
it's a furnace that was burning so hard
it's like i'm gonna i'm gonna get this
i'm gonna achieve this
and from that moment on it was it was
fun for the races
i was trying to figure out a way the
shortcuts to get me to this
this national championship it wasn't
until my senior year
that i actually became the national
champion
and rightfully so
which i think i get this from my father
the night i win the national
championship
i'm sitting there at this point i think
i was 22 i'm sitting there at the
hotel bar with my girlfriend
and i'm having a a rum and coke
and uh first time i drank all year
and i'm having the rum and coke i'm
sipping i had like maybe three sips
and um i'm like what's next
i worked so hard i set this goal and i
worked so hard to achieve this
ultimate goal which is what i think
certain guys
like a conor mcgregor or some of these
guys it's they set that
ultimate goal and then they get there
and it's like
all right that's it i've done it
for me i got there and i'm sitting now
i'm like what's next
all right let's go be an olympic
champion
that was literally that night i decided
what the next goal was
that's gonna be an olympic champion and
then i pursued that
and that's just kind of been the the
recipes rinse and repeat for me
all throughout life and that's where i
am now just on that though
um because i i've interviewed a lot of
successful people and i feel like
part of the gift and the cursive of
being that way
an ultra achiever like yourself is
you don't pat yourself on the back for
long enough you don't enjoy that moment
it's
it's the next drug it's the next chase
it's that
that thing to focus and obsess over
again
and it is very healthy to have something
like that i think it brings the best of
us but
do you ever do you look back and think
maybe i should have enjoyed that
you know a little longer than three sips
of rum and coke
absolutely absolutely because it's it's
um i have guys there's guys right now
that that was it that was it for them
that's the highlight
of their life that's what they talk
about that's what they show their kids
and their grandkids and
and and that's it and there's nothing
wrong with that that's fine
you know but there's just there's
something about guys like myself
is we it's that what's next
we're always chasing that what how can i
out do
what i've just spent a large part of my
life trying to achieve how do i'll do
that
okay that okay we're going to that
and um and yeah that it's a it's a gift
and a courage because
yes it's very very short-lived to where
to the point where
i could for me tell talking to you right
now that's the most i can remember about
the night that i became national
champion
that's the most is having three having
three sips of the roman code
and then saying what's next to my
girlfriend
that that's all i remember really about
it i don't remember the joy of actually
winning it i don't remember any of that
wow you know
yeah it's it is it's truly it's a gift
and it's truly
it's a gift to the curse so how did you
end up on the ultimate fight
instead of going to the olympics then
because that was obviously the focus at
that point
yeah so while i'm living and i'm living
at the olympic training center and i'm
training for the olympics
i get calls by certain fighters and
they're just like hey
i'm going to be fighting a wrestler i'm
going to be
close to your area will you mind coming
up and working out and training with me
and helping me
and uh of course i'm not doing anything
on the weekends all right i'll come up
so i go up and i work with these guys
and so
now i start to get a little taste of
what these guys are going through
and now i'm i'm being exposed more and
more to
fighting as opposed to just living at
the olympic training center training for
the olympics
and then i got um i would watch these
guys
these guys would i would go in and help
these guys and i'm throwing them around
i'm just manhandling some of these guys
of course they weren't throwing punches
in my face but i'm manhandling these
guys
and these guys would go out and compete
and
win the fight in 25 minutes
win the fight and it's they went 100
grand
200 grand 300 grand to where we would
train hard wrestling is such a grueling
sport we train so hard
fly to russia maybe win
such a difficult tournament and you'd
get 2 000
3 000. it's like
as a man who i'm 24 now um i want to be
able to take a hot girl out on a date
you know on the weekend
and you're trying to tell me i can't
even afford that i can't even afford to
take a girl out on a date i can't even
afford to buy a couple of
rum and cokes for the girl at the bar
and so it's like something's got to
change here yeah
and i just went and worked out with this
guy and i was manhandling this guy and
this guy just made 200 grand
oh no i'm in the wrong sport and so
that kind of started to creep in my mind
that
maybe i needed to make a change to a
different sport
and um i got a call by uh
ryan parso's dr ryan parsons who
happened to be the manager for
jason mayhem miller at the time and um
he invited me he said hey mayhem is
going to be the ultimate fighter coach
we're going to need a wrestling coach
heard some good things about you
to mutual friends would you like to be
the wrestling coach on that
and so uh i said sure absolutely it's an
opportunity to be on tv and they're
gonna pay me
to be there absolutely i'm doing it
and then it also gave me more time to be
exposed to fighting
and i went in i did it um it was one of
the
the best things that i ever you know
witnessed been a part of
but it also scared me a lot because
you get to really see the fighting this
wasn't fake these guys weren't faking
this this was real
you get to see these guys hit each other
you get to hear the
sound the con of contact the sound of
the kick when a guy kicks another guy
and i'm like
wait i don't think i'm doing this i
can't do this for a living
that was the first time i was really
exposed to it
and then after that i go back to because
it's different now
when you go through that and then you go
back to wrestling and you're just
wrestling it's not the same
it's like ah not the same that's not as
exciting as that other thing that i just
witnessed
and so it just slowly kind of pulled me
and pulled me until i
decided in 2012 that
i needed to go pursue this because i
would be mad at myself if i never gave
this a chance
so i did and the rest was history
and uh and on the ultimate fighter when
you actually went to compete on the
ultimate fighter which was not long
after that
maybe a couple of years i think you had
like five fights before the
fighter um i watched your first
fight there and i i
obviously i'm like i'm used to seeing
him now and i'm going back to then
and it's it was quite interesting you
know like to see the differences
but in in the first round you took a
front kick to the face
now that's like a knockout for you know
and you just kept coming forward and i'm
like oh yeah [__]
he was the same then you know like that
was
like what's it like to get kicked in the
face like that for a start bro because
that was a big shot that this guy was
pretty good to be fair to him he was
pretty good he was good yeah he was good
to be honest he was probably
the next best guy in that whole show he
was
and um very talented guy
um it was just mentally i was like
wow did i really just take a foot i
didn't realize
in the fight you could a foot could come
to the face that quick
so oh my take it i'm like what was that
was that his foot
and my i'm thinking about that i'm like
was that his foot no i think that was
his foot i just got kicked in the face
i just wait wait here comes here come i
just and so i'm battling this
in the fight but it was one of those
things that i just saw
mentally there was no quit in me nothing
was going to
stop me from from doing what i was doing
nothing was going to stop me from
winning this fight
and i've always had that mentality i
needed to win this fight i was going to
win this
i was going to do everything possible to
win this fight and
and that's just the approach that i took
in that well he got you in a choke
and and when i'm watching this you know
if you lose i've i'm writing
you're out that's it done so and this
guy's choke was pretty deep
and i'm thinking wow if he tapped there
this whole journey this whole thing on
day
by pretty much day one of your ufc
journey could have changed completely
and that
front kick to the face choke that
probably most people tapped you
and you just had that like no quit
energy like you always do but
that could have changed everything like
it's amazing man
yeah when you think about it like that
one fight
yeah you could have been out here dana
white never knew your name none of that
you know
yes yes yes that's that's crazy i
haven't really thought about that but
that's crazy
because um like i said experience i
don't like to have things feel
foreign experience is the best teacher
ever and my second professional fight i
lost the fight
i was i was um i got caught in a choke
and i had to tap because i was gonna go
to sleep
and it was just something about that
loss for me
that it changed everything in my mind
one one of the reasons that i lost i
attribute what i one of the things that
i attribute to
is ignorance i was ignorant in the fact
of thinking that i didn't need to learn
a certain technique um i came in
training and and my wrestling was so
good and so strong to where i could
take guys down and just kind of play
with guys any way that i wanted
on the ground so i never really thought
that
the i never really saw the importance of
learning jujitsu and learning some holds
and chokes and things like that
so me being ignorant like that i was
ignorant going into the fight because
everyone's telling me oh you're gonna
kill this guy you're wrestling so
good you're gonna kill this guy blah
blah blah
and i was ignorant got in the fight boom
took him down
fairly quickly took him down got on top
of him
i'm i'm trying to land punches and then
he starts
doing the juju [__] and he's doing it
and um i'm like oh whoa i've never felt
this before what's going on
and to where now i panic because i never
felt it
and i tried to get up and and and run
out of that situation and then it got
worse and got worse
next thing you know this guy's on my
back and
i'm forced to tap and now i leave that
fight
that feeling was so strong for me that
it was like i never want to feel this
again
so i'm going to do everything possible
to make sure that i never feel this
again
i'm gonna have to be honest with myself
i have to be honest
in my with not myself but in every
aspect of this and since that day i did
i knew that my jiu jitsu sucked at that
point i went and got a geek most
fighters don't train in the ghee because
you don't fight in the game
but i went and got a ghee because i
wanted to learn the sport from
from ground zero and then i did
and i learned it and then staying with
my wrestling staying with the kickboxing
and all of that
and so that built that mentality in me
to when i got in the fight
i had been there before when he got on
my that choke in the ultimate fighter
i've been here before i felt this
and i am not to happen because if i tap
at that moment i don't know what the
future would be
it's going to be very difficult to see
the future if i tap and
so no way it's not happening so i just
have to stay here either i'm going to
just be choked unconscious or i'm going
to die here trying to get out of
it and and that's just kind of how that
i was able to get out of that and it
also like you said
psychologically it's like wow i got
through it because i didn't give up
i got through that and it was just it
reinforces that
yeah of course is it you know you can't
just quit when it's tough you know
i just stayed with it got through it now
i learned something else
you can get through certain things then
you can be tough when you get through it
and so you know all of these things just
kind of added together
helping me get through that show and
once i got through that show and then
won the finale
it was like there's no stopping me here
you know the ironic thing
kamaru is you said you stood up in front
of the wrestling class
and said i'm going to be national
champion whereas everyone else has
a lot more realistic goals so to speak
on the ultimate fighter as i was
watching the show
everyone's talking about winning the
show you're talking about being world
champion
and that again showed why you were
different to everyone there and i
and just having that memory flashback
now it's it's crazy how that same
attitude was present even in the
ultimate fighter too
yeah it's crazy they just showed it a
little clip of it they they played a
little clip a couple days ago
when um and i don't even i didn't even
remember it but even in the
first episode my whole
thought process was that world
championship fight
of me and i'm like
i really was putting myself in the world
championship fight my first fight in the
ultimate fighter that i might not
make it into the ufc unbelievable but
i'm
thinking of that and i'm thinking that's
that's how they're going to announce
and i'm i'm saying the announcement how
bruce buffer is gonna announce us
coming into that world championship
fight and
it's so surreal because that's exactly
how it happened
and wow i i just the power of the mind
and manifesting some of these things
it's incredible
it's funny how dream chasers like
yourself and other fighters who've
spoken
very early in their career about you
know a lot of people talk about what
mcgregor used to
to say and things like that but there's
a lot of fighters who've called a shot
way before it happened
that's what separates average people
from special people
no disrespect but like there's a lot of
people who are like those kids in that
classroom
when you're saying i want to be national
champion and they're the ones who point
and laugh at people like you
but you know you're the one laughing now
bro
very true absolutely true and there's
nothing wrong with that
that's that's my thing there's nothing
wrong with that people uh people put
limitations on themselves all the time
there's nothing wrong with that if you
feel like if you feel like
i can only lift 10 pounds that's fine
that's what you feel like
but you'll never know if your mind
doesn't open up and push yourself
you would never know if you could lift
that 15 pounds
and and and that's that's okay that's
just where you're at that's your
limitation
and um and i didn't see that for me
it's funny when i when i left
the olympic training center the day i
left
and i said i was going to go be a mixed
martial artist
i i got twitter for the first time
i i just got twitter okay and my my
twitter handle was
um i i want to say it said
future welterweight champion
i want to say it said i think it said
that for a long long time i love it
um and then i remember actually changing
it now i don't remember because it's
been a little while but i remember
actually changing it to where i'm like
this is actually happening this happened
i'm world champion yeah got to change
the future out of it
yeah it's surreal
looking back at your beginning of the
ufc run there was a lot of wrestle heavy
performances dominating everyone no one
could touch you
and even in your interviews though there
were it was like
you weren't confident you weren't you
you were a little stiff and
um you were certainly not speaking like
the person we know now
and there was one fight uh the alves
fight
and i don't know if this was a conscious
thing
or what happened between the fight
before and the alves fight but you came
out
with a you know you were battering him
on the feet you were speaking
confidently
you were talent you were talking in you
know you know your home tongue and
you who you were like i was just
wondering when i watched all those
fights back
what happened between that fight and the
ones before was that a decision
yeah it's um it's something that people
that this is the back side that people
don't
don't ever see and don't understand is
um
leading up to those fights um i get out
of the ultimate fighter
um and i had a i had a big knee surgery
oh big big knee surgery that was
supposed to take nine months to just
recover to get rehab i fought three
months
after the surgery um
so i get done with that and that was
probably not the best
idea because now everything that i'm
doing after that
i'm just trying to catch up because i
did more damage
and um then the first fight after that i
remember i was just
i couldn't walk for most of the fight
camp
just walked to my house inside my house
up the stairs to my bedroom i was having
bad bad knee issues and
when you start to experience things like
that it starts to diminish
your confidence in in your abilities
because i know i have a bum knee i don't
i'm not confident in my striking i'm not
confident in
my jiu jitsu or anything else i'm not
confident in that
but wrestling this is something that
i've been doing since i was
14. and i did it for a high enough level
to where i became the national champion
and i was chasing the olympic gold medal
at one point so this is something that's
just kind of ingrained in me
and it's it's an edge that i knew that i
had on some of these guys
so in those fights i was dealing with so
much
you know trauma leading up to it to
where
i would go into the fight and
okay we got to do what we know because
i'm not confident
in my striking because i know i have one
leg
but once i take these guys down i'm
confident here
one leg or not i have the upper hand so
i get through one fight i just
but i needed to win you can't lose you
can't lose here
i'm in the ufc now my goal is to beat
the world champion i can't
lose any in order to be a world champion
so i get i want to get through the fight
okay i win the first fight okay i won
the fight it wasn't that impressive
because i
arrived i wrestled i used my tool
second fight same thing still dealing
with the
the injuries i'm not confident in it i
win the fight
third fight same thing i'm not that
confident
i still go out there to win so now
people start to understand people know
that there's a guy
here that can win yeah you could win but
impress us show us something
you know and i started to feel that
inside i started to feel that i could
have done more on that performance
could have done more than the fourth
fight
i believe uh i fought the russian and
after the first two rounds he was so
tired because i i was able to take him
down and do whatever i wanted
i knew i could have done more but it was
just in the third round
something happened he got himself in a
position too close and by
just the second nature i took him down
again dominated him
and i remember walking away from that
fight and i just felt
i could have done more than i showed
yeah
i had worked on more than that i learned
more than that i had more skills than
that
sorry to interrupt you i remember your
corner um sort of
demanding that of you in that final
round saying
what are you doing get him out here
finish him and exactly
you could see you wanted to but it was a
little bit of a mental block as well
maybe i don't know
yeah it was a bit of a mental block
because i was i was battling between
giving up this position in order to
potentially finish him
or completely continue to dominate him
by not giving up this position
and and that was it and i of course best
case scenario i want to
dominate him in this position and
eventually finish him but he was still a
fighter he was going to fight so he was
going to give me one or the other
this decision of this decision lose the
position but potentially finish him
or stay with the position and you just
dominate him
and i chose to stay with the position
and dominate him and
i just remember walking away from that
fight yes i won but i was just like i
have way more to show than that
and then in the next fight it wasn't a
fight that i necessarily wanted
i believe the ufc kind of put the fight
on me
yeah they were like no you're gonna take
that fight because the guy was a
dangerous guy
he was an ultimate fighter winner as
well finished everybody
he's knocking guys out or choking guys
out
and it was a scary fight
and i remember preparing and training
hard for that fight
and then something happened two weeks
before the fight
i tore some cartilage in my ribs
and by me tearing those cartilage in my
ribs what it did
is now i couldn't get into a wrestling
stance now i couldn't wrestle
oh and and now
like it was even just turning was
so painful but that's all i could deal
with
i couldn't i couldn't do anything else
so the only thing that i can do is stand
there and
throw punches that didn't hurt him
grappling and wrestling all of that
heard it big time
and i couldn't say i pull out of the
fight because they had said
you're gonna fight this fight you're
gonna travel all the way to brazil
and you're gonna fight that fight or
there's gonna be consequences
and um i just said you know what
[__] it let's let's go do it let's go do
it so i remember i got to brazil
and i talked to my my jiu jitsu coach is
a brazilian
george santiago and i remember i asked
him
how do you ask you know in portuguese
how do you ask somebody if they're tired
and um he tells me how to ask
you know and speaking in portuguese and
so i had learned a little bit because i
had a lot of teammates that were
brazilians so i learned how to say some
of the bad words in portuguese
so now we get in the fight and this guy
has watched me
for the last four opponents wrestle them
take them down and just
wrestle them and wrestle them and
wrestle them he prepared for me to
wrestle him
what he didn't prepare for me to do is
stand there and fight him
and i remember i got into the fight
right away and i'm i'm just
because i came in with the attitude of i
don't care what happens
i can't wrestle because my ribs are hurt
he doesn't know that but i can't wrestle
at all so i have to stay here and fight
him
and we started going and i could tell in
the first round he was
his eyes was shocked because he was
waiting for me to try to wrestle him
he was waiting he was waiting he was
waiting but i was just there
trying to fight him and fight him and
fight him and he was spending
so much energy just expecting
me to wrestle him to where i was just
like
i'm trying to assess the situation here
i'm like wait
this is the killer that i watched on tv
several times
and i'm in here with him and he's not a
killer right now
he's he's expecting me to do something
that i'm not
trying to do and then i think it was
about
at the end of that round i spoke to him
in portuguese
and i got in his face and i asked him
are you tired
and i saw his eyes go like this
he was because he was tired he was like
he was extremely tired but he didn't
expect me
to speak his language and ask him if he
was tired
and then in the second round he was a
different guy
i just knew at that point i broke him
mentally i broke him i just stepped on
the gas i was coming
forward then i started hitting him with
shots hitting him with shots
and then i got to the point where i said
this is a fist fight
i signed up to be in a fist fight
i'm down to have a fist fight right now
yeah
and that was when i just i really broke
through i let it fly and i said
i'm here for a fist fight i'm gonna
fight this guy
don't get me wrong if i need to rely on
my tools
i'm gonna rely on those tools because at
the end of the day the most important
thing is winning
but i'm here for a fist fight then we
had a fist fight
and after that moment i just said you
know my attitude going into these five
was approaching them wrong
you know in the beginning i was just
trying to win
now i understand that i'm in a fist
fight yes of course women is the most
important
thing but my attitude now is not just
winning it's winning but winning
impressively because i'm in the fist
fight now
and that's the switch that i flipped
my mind into where now even now in these
championship fights
to where most guys of course want to be
conservative
i'm starting to open up more because i
understand what i'm up against
yeah a lot a lot of people compare you
to obviously georgetown pierre
and um you know all due respect of the
to the legend that he is but
that that right there i think is what
separates you and him because
at that moment you decided i'm not an
athlete yeah you know i'm a fighter
and when i watched you sort of um
taunting him and showing real spite
it's important to have that edge that
edge is what to me
can take you to that next level when you
do start looking at everyone
uh offended that they'd even think they
could beat you you know and
and that dominant edge that you had over
him and the way you just
chased them down like pray um
you know i understand don't get me wrong
george is great and but
you're just a different animal to me
when i when i watch you in this a
different type of thing
altogether and i think maybe that injury
um kind of forced you to learn that
about yourself so
again another another thing that we
think is a negative but actually
is a blessing like you say no it
absolutely
absolutely did and and this is all why
my mind and my psyche works the way it
does because
certain times you expect certain things
to be a detriment like
you know the circumstances that you have
in life that
where you grew up and where you're
dealing with and not having this
now not having that now for me
not being healthy going into that fight
it was a blessing in disguise because it
prepared me for
that moment to where i had to say you
know what
i don't need to rely on wrestling i have
to stand here
and i have to find a way to still
accomplish this goal
and that's kind of how my my mind works
now that's how my life works
especially in this last fight in the
first fight
you see that i fought him twice and this
is the exact
moment that i'm talking about in the
first fight i'm coming into the fight
with the broken nose
[Music]
it makes me a little wary because if
you've ever had a broken nose you know
that if someone even just
swings the hand past your face you it's
you feel
you feel it and i'm dealing with all of
that going into the fight
but i have to keep on a strong face and
somehow
win the fight because i'm the champion i
have to stay the champion
and i did all that i could do to win
that fight but i knew that that wasn't
my best
that it wasn't the best that i could do
which is why i was offended
that of course he started running his
mouth and saying that oh no
this is why that fight went the way it
did because
because of him when i knew it was
because of me
and so i said all right let's do it
again i didn't have to do that
i've already solved that puzzle i didn't
have to do it but i said you know what
let's do it again
because i want to put a definitive end
to this i want you to understand
that the level between you and i so far
that this is how i'm going to show and
then that second fight
there was not i wouldn't have been
satisfied any other way
than the way it happened i needed to put
him there i needed to lay him there
to where when he woke up he was like wow
okay
um there's absolutely nothing i can say
now yeah
are you a good problem solver you know
in in everyday life because i
i when i'm writing when i watch people
and look at people i think
this guy is he's a he must be
mechanically minded or something because
he
he's a bit of a problem solver i can say
that you really go into every deal
that is that is a fight that me and my
girlfriend have a little bit nowadays
sometimes women don't want you to solve
the problem they just
want to be able to talk about the
problem yeah
and and i'm i'm like i don't want to
talk about the problem
there's a problem there's a equation a
way to solve it
let's do it yep and that's how my mind
works and even in life
like i my daughter has a problem what's
the problem
oh that's that's wrong okay let's fix
that
how can i help you fix that my brother
has a problem what's the problem
let me help you fix it it's very
practical for sure yes i'm
very very practical to sometimes it
hurts because even
my girlfriend is we we talk about these
certain times
certain things and it's like i just want
to solve it if you're hurting
something's going on i don't want you to
hurt i want to be able to help you
get out of that heartache so you don't
hurt it must be difficult
to be the girlfriend of yourself because
you know you're a champion of the world
for
for the because you're unusual you're an
unusual dude
and part of what makes you great could
probably make day-to-day living with you
quite a challenge for her because she's
like i know you're like
the guy who thinks to the far end of the
world about these problems but like
can we just be normal for a minute yeah
you know
do you know what i mean yeah yeah
absolutely absolutely and
um and that's one thing too that i i
don't shy away from because i'm
discovering that about myself
i don't shy away from it i i understand
that it's a
it's a challenge and and
i'm it's a challenge that i'm up to you
know i'm up to dealing with
like i have a daughter yeah of course i
want a son
to where i can no pick it up let's go be
tough
you know get through it you know don't
be lazy be strong
yeah but on the contrary i have to be
able to be soft enough
to deal with the emotions of my daughter
sometimes she just wants to whine
sometimes she just wants me to hold her
sometimes she wants me to just touch her
to be
close to her to keep her safe and i
understand that i'm starting to i grow
each and every day when i'm around her
because i'm starting to understand
all of that you're very good at that by
the way i've watched a lot of like
little
uh social media posts of you and uh
watching you with your daughter i think
is where fans are going to
really start warm to you because it is
that different side and a lot of
fighters are scared to show stuff like
that because
they want to be the bad ass all the time
you know but i think
um seeing people like yourself and um
and and and all the other fighters now
it's becoming more common and i think
it's a it's a great thing to see that
yeah i i think i i think that's what
makes me um that's what keeps me human
it keeps me sane
is is my ability to still be able to
adapt
knowing that i'm dealing with some of
these things which could be extreme for
the masses
but i'm still able to bring it down and
um
and deal with everyday life like my
daughter like she wants to do this she
wants to play she wants to do that i'm
still able to deal with these things and
i think that's what makes me
different and sets it still keeps me
human you know at the end of the day
i seen her cooking your breakfast this
morning how was it
it was good it was good she's uh she's
learning um
she's learned a lot and
it's one of those things that still
makes me smile on the inside when i see
[Music]
how things are are just starting to
unfold for me
you know dealing with the life of being
a fighter and all of that and
and now coming home and just having her
the simplicity of
cooking together or watching the movie
together
all these things are things that i i
don't take for granted
and then i truly truly cherish is that
really helpful for you as well because
kind of
you are then forced to stop being
the champ and and be dad and
and for an obsessive person like you
that you know there is no off switch but
with with a daughter who's just looking
up at you with her eyes like that
it it forces that off switch to happen
because she is that'll switch
absolutely and um the biggest example
that i could
give and um is
if you look at um
you look at the last fight there's
there's a moment to
right at the end of the fight there's a
moment that you get to
that you just like as a
it's the ultimate i call it the ultimate
macho moment
i just knocked this guy out unconscious
and at that point it's like blackout i'm
blacked out
mo i'm this ultimate macho guy i'm at
the top of that i don't even remember
what i'm doing i'm at the top of the
cage i'm beating my chest
i jump off i'm at the ultimate height of
adrenaline
i'm back inside the cage and i'm
watching the
replay i'm inside the cage now
and i'm still at this moment this grand
moment
and then the camera gets away for a
little bit
and then you come back and then it pans
out it's literally
three seconds the camera goes away for
three seconds and comes back
and i'm on my knees my daughter's in the
cage and i'm
she just she comes in i see her she
comes in
flips the switch boom that guy's gone
and i'm dead and and that happens a lot
now and i think obviously god knew what
he was doing by giving us daughters
because i'm at the point where i'm being
honest if it was a son
you know it'd be a little different like
yeah a son you see that daddy yeah we
did it son
yeah and you continue to exude all that
machoness
but she steps in and she's just like
it's like i have a switch you flip that
switch i'm the nigerian nightmare i'm in
there i'm i'm
macho and she just comes in and she up
turns it down there's nothing i can do
about it
yeah i i had a few emotional moments
watching you celebrate some fights but i
i will i want to talk about that in a
second but um
rewinding back to on on the come up here
you fought a couple of guys
um there was mek um and
maybe damien meyer as well around that
period of time
there was quite a lot of criticism uh
towards you
and i just wondered how you how you deal
with that because
like you said at the start of the
podcast you know we all want to be loved
and you're essentially displaying
your art you're you you've worked very
hard behind the scenes and you're
putting that on show
and when people don't appreciate it and
i think every fight fan is is guilty of
being hot
over the top with criticism i i don't
know what it's like to be on your side
where you're the one pouring
your heart out bleeding and giving
everything in there to then feel
underappreciated what is that like
it's hard it's hard i'm not gonna lie
it's very very
very hard because
it's not so much that i you want to be
liked if you want to be acknowledged
and so it makes it harder to win people
to acknowledge it but they acknowledge
it
in a bad way oh like so getting booed
and stuff like that did that happen yeah
i was booed last fight yeah but like
what i mean is booed because
there's there's being booed because
you're the bad guy and then there's
being booed because they don't enjoy
watching you fight
i know you know like what what is that
like when you're here right it sounds
but it sounds the same yeah i suppose
it sounds the same yeah so how are you
how are you supposed to know
right then and there whether they're
born because
they don't you know they don't like the
way you fight
or the fact that they just don't like
you
or whether that you're the bad guy you
can't really decipher because you can't
meet each individual person and ask them
hey why are you bowling why are you
going
no they're booing so it sounds the same
so it's just psychological at that point
your mind
tells you why they're born so if your
mind that day is feeling like they're
born because they just don't like me
okay if your mind tells you that they're
booing because
they don't like the way you fight okay
you know and this is my last fight
obviously my mind is blowing
they were booing in my mind tell me
they're booing because
you're in south you're in florida this
guy's from south florida
even though i live in south florida too
i wasn't raised here these guys
know him for being from south florida so
that's why they're born
but that's fine i know how to deal with
that i'm quit equipped mentally to being
able to deal with that
so all of that plays a factor but
in that in that time period it was
difficult because
you just at some point yeah it's like
okay i want to be
world champion in order for me to become
world champion
like i have to continue to win i have to
continue to be successful what i'm doing
and obviously you have to be able to
acknowledge
that i'm good enough to be world
champion
and when then the criticism is like uh
we don't care for him oh we don't like
him or this and that
it does hurt i'm a human being it hurts
yes of course
i'm it's like me painting this
masterpiece over here
and then you look at it you're like uh
i'll pay a dollar for that
it's like no this is a masterpiece this
is worth millions no i'll pay a dollar
for it
now that's hard it's heartbreaking and
and that's at that moment that's kind of
what i was dealing with in that time and
it uh
it was hard but like i said you know
it's one of those things that you get
through and you appreciate later on
so now i appreciate that and your your
first what i would class is a really
big name well wayne was the former
champion das anos
um and and you did that in
scarily easily fashion like this guy was
really well respected
and you just made him look like a child
really it was brutal um were you aware
then that what was on the line that the
title shot was coming next
yeah i think um i was starting to be on
that cusp of
me knowing that i want to be world
champion
that's it i i want to be world champion
so at this point
i don't care who i have to beat up and
their their brothers and sisters that i
have to beat up
i need to be world champion so line them
up
i want to be world champion with him
i don't want to say i was looking past
him i wasn't looking past him
i fully prepared for him but i was
already
my mind was i was going to be the world
champion
and so this guy was in my way and i
needed to get rid of him
and so that's that's just kind of how i
took it into that fight and
you know with the big respect because i
respect him a lot
you know he was the true champion and um
you know once i got through him it was
just like i don't know when this world
title shot's gonna come
but when it does come i'm i'm gonna be a
champion
did you feel like they were reluctant to
give you it given that your style was
mostly wrestling and they were kind of
like you know is not gonna draw in the
money
yes but yeah but i i didn't give him a
choice
i kind of put him in a place to where
if you didn't give it to me i was gonna
beat everybody in the division
where i didn't care if i needed to beat
everyone from 1 to 15
i was going to be the only guy there to
where you're going to be like oh wow
who's next for the title
he's the only guy we have to give it to
him you know i was
well prepared to do that i think what
went in your favor as well as i don't
think they had the greatest relationship
with woodley
uh god bless them either so they were
like yeah
you'll [__] now yeah yeah so that
i think that was a big key too inside
it's basically sometimes they put unique
positions to where it's like
well who's gonna be the biggest
challenge for you that could bring the
best
out of you and they do that
and with woodley it was like okay well
who's going to be the biggest challenge
to bring the best
out of you because you can't just
go in and wrestle a guy you can't just
walk away
and back up and back up and not create
the action
who's going to come after him and at
that point i think he was
you know i was on the short list for
that
and that's why that worked in my favor
and like you said earlier you
you had planned for woodley's for so
long
to the rest of the world this was a very
evenly matched fight if if anything
woodley was probably favorite because
you know i remember joe rogan comparing
him to jsp and people were talking like
is he
you know they were there were
conversations i'm not not saying he was
as good as him but there were certainly
conversations
and the way he was getting rid of people
in really impressive fashion
the way you beat him was a stat
outstanding it was one of the best title
win performances
it was so dominant it was as dominant as
any title win
outside of a one-punch knockout you can
you can get really
i guess relentless is the word in there
it was like i
am not losing this this is mine you will
not take this from me
yeah i mean i knew it years ago i
already knew it
it was just it's i was
lucky and and and
luck for me is when you know preparation
meets opportunity
and i had been prepared for this for so
many years
and then now i got the opportunity
i was like oh my goodness this is
and even in the press conference
i remember we were having the press
conference and
i couldn't tell if he was just trying to
sell the fight or if he was
really being honest with himself because
that's one thing that i
am is being honest with myself my
abilities and my opponent's abilities
and he would ask me
because i had known woodley like i said
i respected him and i had a conversation
with him when he was champion when he
first became champion
i was fortunate enough to where because
rashad i was with rashad evans all the
time
and they were friends and rashad evans
is kind of like the mentor the godfather
for
all us athletes you know and um
and you know rashad took me to one of
his after parties with woodley
and i remember i got a quick by a second
he was sitting next to me and i'm
next to him i'm like i'm sitting with
the champion
and i'm like and i asked him and i said
hey
what is it what is it what's the
difference what does it feel like you
being
world champion and he's like oh well
you know what's not much difference i to
be honest i don't really remember his
answer
but i just remember how i felt being
around him
like i totally know what you mean though
yeah yeah and then
you could you knew you could take him
just by being next to him
yeah yeah being next to him feeling his
aura feeling his presence
and then fast forward to what three
years later and i'm i'm sitting there
and i'm
um we're having this press conference
and he brings it up
and i asked him that in confidence like
that's i'm looking up to you
you know you're the champion i respect
you
and i asked him that and confident he
brought it up and he's like what are you
going to do
what can you do better than me you can't
do anything better than me it was almost
like he had disdain like he didn't care
for my skills and my mental capability
when i already knew
three years ago that i could be and
and i told him i said everything and he
said
if it was just we were just boxing i
would knock you out
and i knew we could do it and we were
just grappling i would
break your arm i knew you could do it he
said he would beat me
every way shaped former fashion i told
him
no you cannot that's what i can do to
you and i will do to you
and he brought up that fact that i asked
he's like remember what you asked me
a couple three or four years ago now
that got me by surprise because i
that's that's like between men that's
something we talked about
yeah and he brought it up and it was
just like
wow this guy really
is do he doesn't understand what's going
on right now he's delusional
and to this point i still don't think he
understands what happened in that fight
because even every interview he does now
it's still like he's like oh well
i don't know what i was like i had an
out-of-body experience i wasn't even
into that fight i don't know what
happened you said it was like a bad
dream and
what i love is that your nickname is the
nigerian nightmare it's like
like literally bro they're closing the
name pal you've just had a nightmare
but what i love about the fact that he
he gave you sort of a nonchalant
response to being the champion
and it and it goes back to sort of that
thing that we were talking about of
thoughts become things it's that
it's that you know that drive that you
have about you that obsessive
i will get this nature and for someone
to speak about the thing that you're
working day in day out for
as if it's no it's all right like you
knew straight away
he didn't want it as much as you wanted
it just by hearing that answer
you couldn't even remember the exact
words but the toner voice told you
enough
absolutely i knew it at that point i
knew it and
and um another thing that i remember
from the night is we were walking away
when we were leaving that the club and
we're walking away and i just
just his presence is aura the way he
walked away and i'm like
this guy's not good i would i would take
from this guy
i will be i will be the world champion
uh now at that point i
i didn't necessarily know that it would
be me
fighting him for the belt i just knew i
could take him
but that's a powerful signal and it's
nothing that we can't explain but it is
very
animalistic and i think i feel like when
you guys get in the cage
there's there's this [__] that you just
can't put words to but that is
it's going on it's happening oh yeah and
he
felt and and honestly this is just gonna
have to be one of the
it's gonna have to be a conversation
that i'm going to expect from him at one
at some point in life before we pass on
is
is having that man-to-man conversation
to where i could ask him certain
questions and he can be honest with me
and he can ask me certain question i'll
be honest with him is
is i wanted him i want to know from him
whether he
felt my aura in there because
when i stepped into that cage that was
my cage that night
with him that was mine and
and i watched back and i just i could
see it from just the way that i
approached each round and after each
round
and my my confidence my my mystique in
there
to where i want to know from him if he
felt the same thing that i felt
you know but that's that's a
conversation for another time and
and it's kind of one of those things
that you know warriors always want to
soldiers they want to talk to each other
you know later on
i like that like rocky and apollo type
stuff yeah
back together over a beer that would be
good yes
speaking of tyron um i i recently
interviewed jake paul
and he's now signed to fight jake paul
um and and i kind of i did a video
recently about this because
it seemed like the minute tyron woodley
signed to fight jake paul
everyone started discrediting him and
talking about him as if he was
an easy fight oh jake paul's not trying
to get a real fight i'm and i was kind
of like
have you seen what boxers do in their
early fights tyron woodley
to be fair to jake paul for his fourth
fight or whatever it is
is a [__] hell of a task considering
tyron woodley
beat darren till the year jake paul
started
learning boxing like that it's a crazy
fight but
i wondered um what your take on them too
matching up would be
yeah i i always find it very
disrespectful that
people try to do that because you know
even though
i i faced tyron woodley and i was able
to defeat him i still don't discredit
what he did and what he's done i mean
this man was a devastating striker and i
think still
is you know i just think uh on the
mental edge side of it
i think he's he's he's not there
necessarily right now
but he's still tyrant woodley and
it's a hell of a fight for jake paul if
jake paul is able to get through
tyron woodley then now he
is in a realm where i can say okay now
you you know
you can make a case for me wanting to
step in there and whoop your ass
you know um it's it's and i yeah and
people of course
people start trying to discredit him all
but he lost his last three fights in
this map or did you see his last
15 before that and he had a murderer's
role in in his defeats
he thought you he for um
uh burns burns colby covington
these are top five guys like it along i
mean
you know colby and you are right
like up there with the greatest
welterweights of all time and i think
tyron woodley
in his prime you could make an easy case
of him being top five walt away of all
time
you know yeah i i agree and that's the
dangerous thing about this division that
we're in
is once you you take that defeat
it's not there's not rebound guys to
where it's it's a lesser guy let me
bounce back
no you've got another killer waiting for
you and another killer waiting after
that and another guy after that
and um you know it's one of those tough
tough situations to be in but i still
give him credit tyler woodley is turning
willie and i'm
i'm intrigued now i have to watch that i
gotta watch that fight
you know i absolutely kind of have to
watch that fight now there's a lot of
people calling jake paul a fake fighter
um if he wins this fight or if he even
looks
good at points do you do you think that
that is enough for him to be
considered a real fighter
you know no i i i don't like that term
of
fake he's a fake fighter i don't like
that term a fake fighter is someone
who's doing it in the movies
stunt you know just doing the moves
not really
you know doing the moves and fights and
not really actually engaging it
yeah you know this this young kid is
still
climbing inside the ring and doing it
and doing it in front of
thousands and thousands of people so
much respect
with him being able to bear his soul
like that
you know but i think what rubs people
the wrong way is
when you haven't faced the level of
opposition
you know as far as professionals to
really call yourself
you know you're the one of the best to
do this and then you're saying oh i'm
one of the greatest i'm good at this
when you start doing that i think that's
what rubs people the wrong way to where
people are
are you know starting to have that
you know disdain for you they're just
like oh you're not a real fighter
you know no but he's a real fighter
because he does get inside a boxing ring
put on the boxing glove and actually
compete
so for that i will give him a real
fighter but as far as
being an elite fighter like tyron once
was
no he's not there yet yeah and jake
obviously is um
he's making mega money that that
you know probably i think the the
numbers came out for like the top three
fighters financially in the last year
and like
he was level with anthony joshua so i
think that is another thing is people
are looking at
you know he fought ben oscar and and
they and i think other fighters are kind
of
frustrated when they say that but i
wonder if it's made
people like yourself view the fight game
a little differently and think more
about um
content and and and getting your name
out there and
playing the game a bit more the way
people like conor mcgregor have
that's that's the tough that's the tough
part about
my situation is um when i got into it i
didn't get into it necessarily for
for all of that i didn't get into this
because i wanted
um to be famous or i wanted to be known
worldwide i didn't get into it for that
i also didn't get into it for
you know necessarily for the money i
didn't get into it for that aspect
you know of course i wanted the money
but
it was it was just for for the fact that
i wanted to compete and i wanted to be
the best at what i was doing
that was one of the main reasons why i
got into it so now
when you get to see all these guys that
are are actually
now there and making that money
and doing that it's almost kind of
almost like they cut the line
but i'm content with myself because that
wasn't my goal
this is their goal for them to be famous
for them to you know
to get oh yeah i'm i'm a fighter whether
you're not
you know you haven't fought the level of
opposition of competition yeah
for them to be famous and known all
across because yeah he's making
headlines making a lot of headlines
whether it's for the wrong reasons
it doesn't matter he's making those
headlines but
that wasn't my goal so i don't really
care about that aspect
but it does open eyes like this
is the amount of money that we can make
why aren't we making that
and we are actually fighters who are
fighting the level of opposition
so in that aspect yes it does it
definitely does open a lot of eyes
but um the majority of it i'm not
conflicted with it because um
i'm not that wasn't my goal is to be
famous and
in that aspect no speaking of you making
money he's actually
jake's actually been speaking out
against dana white a lot about
you need to pay your fighters more you
need to make the jon jones and gone if i
give the people what they want sort of
thing
i'm not going to put you in the position
of asking you know do you agree or
whatever
because i respect that you've got a
business situation but i wondered if any
other usa fighters had mentioned that to
you or
or talked about it in private that he's
bringing
the guy to talk about that no i mean
not necessarily that he's the guy that's
talking about it absolutely it's uh
what a lot of what we all feel
to be honest it's what we all feel i
don't know what you get paid
um you know doing your podcasts and then
you know what not but it's never enough
never gonna be enough yeah true you give
me you you give me a hundred thousand
today guess what by tomorrow i'm
i already got a hundred thousand i want
a million now yeah you know i want to
feel what that feels like
you give me a million uh i want to feel
what 10 million feels like
you know that's the story of man
especially any ambitious man
of course that's what we do we want to
progress
so it's never going to be enough for me
becoming a
state champion wasn't enough national
champions not enough
world champion is still not enough you
know it's never going to be enough so
absolutely in that aspect yeah could we
be making more
absolutely absolutely should we make
more yes
you know give me all the money in the
world let me have it all in my
bank account i guarantee you still not
gonna be enough yeah
you know so yeah in that aspect yeah
should we get paid more
absolutely uh him he's speaking out
about it
um but there's there's a lot of
differences there's a lot of things in
the boxing world that a lot of boxers
had to deal with
mike tyson being the main one to you
understand
there's a a lot of situations and a lot
of things that they had to deal with
that is simplified with what we do
completely simplified to where we just
sell contract to fight
all right sign got our managers and
their trainers and we go deal with it
to wear boxes back in the day where you
had so many hands that had to touch your
okay the promoter had to touch it the
manager had this still
still to this day by the way like boxing
is still [__] for that like people
people pay all the attention to floyd
money mayweather and all of that
what they don't realize is that the
grassroots of boxing
these guys are getting robbed and
getting punched in the face at the same
time
and like you might make a few thousand
and before you know it you're paying
you know you're left with a couple of
thousand max when you walk away
like it the the one thing that ufc does
do which i don't think they do get a lot
of credit for is that the grassroots at
the early stages
they pay those guys way better than
boxing does
but it's about finding the balance and
that's obviously
when you bring in a wme they're going to
want to take a lot of
those profits um but on the jake paul
thing
you know there was a lot of rumors that
you guys might end up fighting
and i know due to the conor and floyd
situation that the ufc would have to
okay that
how have you had any talks because he
claimed i think when
someone on his side claimed there was
talks has there been any discussion of
any kind
um they they threw it at us they they
threw it at us a couple of times but
then we really start to
um really wasn't something that i wanted
to entertain
at first because it's think about it
what does it do
for me besides you know potentially
money
that's the really the only upside in it
you know this guy's improving to where
it's like oh you just beat a killer you
know that your respect
level has gone up no even if this guy
lands up if he lands one punch on me
then it's like oh
he landed a punch on you you know you
know that that
that did nothing for me except
money-wise
so then you know they reached out here
and there and then it's like we have to
really start to dissect this
you know i didn't pay that much
attention but that's why my manager
that's what i paid him for
you know that's his job where he starts
to you know really dissect this now
these guys are saying the numbers that
these guys are reporting that they're
doing
it's not really the numbers they're
doing you know
for you to come out and say okay you did
one point something million pay-per-view
buys
that's not true you know because my
manager dude did his do homework to
where he had to actually
look at the real numbers and see if it
makes sense if you're doing 1.7 million
pounds and you're fighting nobody
now you better you get a chance to fight
the real world champ the reigning world
champion
now that we have to look at those
numbers
and by looking at the numbers my manager
said this made no sense
because they're reporting numbers that
that's not necessarily true it's not res
that's not what they're really making so
if they're not making that
then the only aspect the only upside of
you even
fighting him would have been the money
so if the numbers and reporting is not
really accurate
then there's really no upside because
that money is not going to be able to be
you know accounted for so you know there
was no upside it didn't make sense
um i appreciate you thinking that way
though because
other fighters such as floyd mayweather
don't think that way
and it's funny that someone who's
building a legacy right now
is protecting it the way you are um
whereas other people like floyd maybe
don't care as much and you just want the
money and whatever but
i think part of the reason why fans like
myself have really grown and warmed to
you
is because other fighters
are so um scarce with their appearances
in the ufc sometimes whereas
you and izzy for example you are
constantly in there and we get
i can invest in you because you invest
in yourself and you
you care about getting in there so that
i can now care about you way more
because i know
like you can be my favorite fighter
because i'm going to see you all the
time and i
i'm on the journey with you whereas
these fighters who
you know um yeah i was a huge mcgregor
fan for example you know
you see these guys once every two three
years sometimes and it
it's like it's not enough if you if you
really want us to care
and i think you're going about your
career very smartly so i want to give
you credit for that
thank you thank you i appreciate that
and it's it's one of those things too
it's
i'm i'm i actually try to think about
where i'm at in life like we mentioned
when i started into the ufc
having knee surgery and not being able i
couldn't even really walk
i'm thinking okay this is going to be
short-lived do i've already
felt what it's felt like to not be able
to compete
so i'm hurt i know that i can't fight
for a long time because i have to
somehow get to a way to where i could
fight
to where now i'm in the point where it's
i just fall
i get out of the fight i'm like wow i'm
relatively still healthy let's
let's what's next let's do it let's see
let's do it again let's do it again
because i'm not getting any younger
you know i'm getting older and at the
same time
these these take a lot more out of you
now preparing for these world title
fights take a lot
out of you a lot of you know
mental strength out of you as well as
physical being able to prepare for these
and so
yeah i acknowledge that i know what it
does and then what it takes from you and
um
i'm just trying to live in the moment
and enjoy it while it's here because
that's one thing that i don't do enough
is actually you know sit back and enjoy
it
enough worry about you a little bit with
the way you're speaking though because
you clearly give so much to your
training and to your performance
and someone else who did that was kane
velasquez
and i always looked at him and i i
personally i think he's right up there
with one of the greatest whoever did it
in his prime especially at heavyweight
i feel like truly if you put him in his
primary heavyweight he probably beats
anyone any other heavyweight there but
but he he gave too much in the training
room and
and he brutalized like other fighters
but he also
trained so hard he brutalized himself
and you
it's a fine line when you're that
obsessive guy and you want to
push harder to not push yourself to a
point where
you're vulnerable absolutely um
but the thing is if you ask kane
would he would he if he had a choice to
do it all over again
would he do it that way
or change it and not knowing what the
outcome would be
and like there's a reason why we still
talk about cain velasquez
is because he was able to go out there
and show us what we saw
yep now had he changed and not been as
hard or
trained as hard would he have been the
world champion
there's been so many ufc fighters but
i would say we can name
one 25th of them you can name them
exactly yeah and so by him
going about it the way that it did it
made him who he was
now it's extremely tough to say okay you
changed that does
you get still get there do we still hear
your name or are you just
another guy who fought in the ufc had a
long career
but no one really knew that's that's a
question that you would have to
give cain velasquez and and it would be
tough it would be very hard me
personally
i don't know if i would change a lot of
things obviously now with the
the wisdom that i have yes i would tweak
certain things here and there
but as far as as hard as i went because
it prepared me for
such a battle to where i knew that
didn't matter what happened
i wasn't going to wilt i was willing to
die in there for this
and and going back to the woodley wayne
after the fight
um when i watched it god i could almost
cry because
you know i've watched all i've watched
literally every fight but back to back
to back
i literally just sat there for a full
day having my tomorrow's monday
um shout out ufc 5 pass by the way thank
you for that
and um and and you have this moment with
your daughter
and you know like before you've been
aggressive in your post-match interviews
i'm a problem all of that i
love that but you just broke down crying
when you say
such a tough guy who never shows that
and you're sobbing with your daughter
and seeing how much she meant to you and
the way you said like you know she put a
fire under me
um that was powerful bro like you got me
right in the heart there
yeah man thinking about it too
uh i i i re i know what that moment felt
like that that's one of those moments
that
i actually do remember is because
i remember the moment i found out that i
was gonna have a daughter
and how scared i was
um i would say two weeks after that was
the first time i've ever had a panic
attack
an anxiety attack i had an anxiety
attack in the hyperbaric chamber
never experienced this i'm a macho guy
whatever it was i'd do it
i had an anxiety attack in
the hyperbaric chamber to where i
literally thought i was
it could be it were you thinking what
were you thinking about at that moment
to make your anxiety attack i was
preparing for my third professional
fight
now keep in mind i lost the second
professional fight okay
and it was about eight months in between
and now throw on i'm gonna have a child
now throw on i have 17
in my bank account now throw on that i'm
living with a friend
on you know on a friend's couch i'm
gonna have a child
and i just remember thinking how am i
going to do this
i can't do this and i'm in the
hyperbaric chamber
and i usually sleep in there and then i
wake up when it's decompressing
but i woke up and it was still going
yeah and so i'm just in there
thinking i'm just in there with my
thoughts and i start thinking wow
okay i just lost my second fight what if
this
third one if i lose this third one two i
have a daughter coming oh my god i
have 17 in the bank account i can't even
go on a date right now
like all these are going through my mind
and i start sweating
next you know my heart starts racing i'm
gonna come down
calm down relax it's okay so and i'm
having this conversation with myself
relax it's okay it's okay but it's
i'm in the room and it's dark in the
room they close the door and they turn
the lights off because i usually sleep
in there
and now i'm no one around
no one to let me out and now i'm
panicking
yep and i just i'm i'm drenched i'm
dripping sweat and
all of a sudden i'm tapping on the the
window on all of a sudden
a nurse comes in and turns the light on
and the
machine starts to decompress so
i hid it i don't think they knew that i
was having an anxiety attack
they just i think they just knew uh they
just
the time was up as soon as she walked in
the time was up and they started to
decompress so i
i was like okay i'm about to get out of
here but
i remember driving home thinking wow
i just had an anxiety attack and
from that moment i went through with it
i had my third professional fight which
i ended up winning
[Music]
and won the fourth and won the fit and
then going through the ultimate fighter
and having my daughter still struggling
and going through that moment
i knew what that did to me having her
and
and to get to the point where now i got
to the goal i got to where i wanted to
be
i wanted to be world champion i'm here
and to be able to share that with her
holding her in there it
broke me on the inside i couldn't even
hide it i could have tried
to be as macho as possible but there's
no way
you could just see that would have been
i loved this i
i loved it and i'm really glad you did
that it's a fun because
it let us know who the real kamaru
uzmini is in that moment
a proud dad was the real person it
wasn't about the belt
it was more about your child and when
you said to her
um i want you to remember this moment
because in years to come we're going to
watch this back together and you're
going to know
daddy did it and it was perfect it was
a beautiful moment honestly it it floors
me even now like she makes fun of me
because i'm so like
i i'll be silly i'm so silly around her
and and she makes she makes fun of me
and then when we go places and people
are like
oh get her in the picture and she'll
make certain comments dave why does
everyone want to take a picture
i love that i love it bro honestly
honestly i love it and the funny thing
is is she's obviously
she's just brought out a totally
different side to you mate and um
and when i watch your videos on um
social and stuff you can see
if anything you're the child and she's
just looking at you like
what do you act like this for like
stress yes
yes definitely i love it man and it's
it's great to see
and um going back to the hype of barrack
chamber
i've got experience with them because i
used to be a diver
um people love that i've mentioned that
because i always talk about it
in stories but when you're in there
people don't understand if you've never
been in there before once that door's
shut
it's it's like being in a jail cell like
you're you
but it's ironically you're pressurized
and what was going through your head was
all the pressure
in your life as well it's some poetic
[__] because you're literally racking
your brains and
i can totally understand how going in
there in the dark
and thinking about all this pressure on
yourself and being a professional
fighter and having
oh no wonder you had a panic attack have
you had any since then
yes i have and i i think that was
i say that was a start of making me
human
again you know because before that i was
just
didn't matter what it was let's do it
this was tough uh let's do i just go
through it
and now it's i think i've had two more
i've had two more since then um
one was actually on a plane on a private
plane
again pressure both times
exactly wow i was uh on a private plane
and
before we took off they they told me
that oh well
it's only a three and a half four hour
flight but
towards the last 35-40 minutes we'll get
a little turbulence
and and i knew that and so i was
prepared for it
i was in there it's just me the flight
attendant the two pilots and were
refined and
everything's smooth and you know i
almost kind of forgot
that they had mentioned that and we're
there
and then all of a sudden starts getting
a little bit of turbulence
and as soon as i get that my mind is
triggered
by what has happened to me in the
hyperbaric chamber
triggered boom now i'm thinking about
that like why do i feel the same as i
felt that
now my mind is going what ifs what is
and i'm like no because that it's like a
rabbit hole once you
fall in you just it just starts to
spiral
yeah so now i'm trying to fight it i'm
trying to pull myself out
mentally and like relax i'm talking to
myself
i'm and it's the attend the flight
attendant she's looking at me
probably it's like a 10-seater so she's
looking at me
she's a couple of seats in front she can
see me and i can see her
and i'm like can i ask her for some
tease can i get some tea
so she turns to making tea as soon as
she turns her back to making tea
i'm freaking out
she makes me tea i grab the tea and i
start drinking and out drinking the tea
and i'm just
now doing breathing exercises in there
and i could tell she
she knew that something was wrong and so
she's
she's like are you okay i'm like yeah
i'm fine fine good i'm
good all good and i'm
and eventually the pilot goes all right
we're preparing for landing i'm like oh
[Music]
i'm gonna get off this plane soon yeah
and
and i got out and i'm thinking oh wow
wow that that's real it really truly
happens because when you're going to
that moment you just um
nothing you know it's it's in your head
but it feels like i'm something i'm
gonna die
yeah that's what it feels like and i
used to always when i was younger i was
like why can't they just
mentally just why could they just turn
it off yep
now i understand that struggle
and uh it's a tough one but um
yeah though those i'm hopefully that's
the last one that i won't get but um
i think you know just maturing through
life certain things bring out certain uh
chapters in certain situations so i
don't think it's a coincidence though
that
you because you know i'm not saying
we're the same person by any means but
one
one of the qualities i feel like i share
with you is that ability to look down
the street and around the corner
as a way of anticipating all the
possibilities so that i can
prepare myself as best as i can to
control the outcome
which i guess is what you know it's made
you a great fighter
but once you're in a a chamber or an
airplane
that control is removed you are at the
mercy of whatever
may happen and that is probably in the
brain where it's gone
i don't like this this is i can't
prepare for anything there is no outcome
i can control it's the pilot
[__] um and i kind of have a similar
feeling sometimes on planes so that kind
of makes sense to me
that's great that's that's it's crazy
that you say that because that was one
of the thoughts that i had on that
private plane was
i can't con we're in the air we're
flying
over a different country yeah i can't
just say
hey land this now or if i okay it's not
a car hey
pull over i can't do that and i remember
having that exact
thought at that moment like wow i can't
just tell them to stop to land right now
so yeah no i i completely understand
that
and once you won you won the title um
you did you ring your father in jail
he uh he he was already sleeping at the
time
okay first thing in the morning of
course first thing in the morning
i got that call and um
you know it's one of those like he's
i can tell he was gonna cry oh
i could tell he was gonna cry but it was
one of those you know he couldn't really
you know because like my dad is a macho
guy you know like he's
i've seen videos of him he's a tough he
looks tough as well
yeah military guy you know so
but now of course with age we are mellow
to where yeah
hill hill i could tell he wanted to cry
and um
but i just knew it i'm i'm that guy i'm
that child that
i don't necessarily need to hear it to
know it i knew how he felt
and um and it meant the world to me that
he was able to
know that yeah i've seen i seen him
interviewed about it and he said he
became like the most famous guy
in in the block he like they loved him
and they were all celebrating for him
which was great yeah
that was that was something that i loved
too about about him
is that i was still able to affect him
and and touch him
while i wasn't but i was
you know whenever i had something coming
up a competition or anything like that
they
all knew to where he still felt a part
of it
he still felt like he was tied to me and
that i was out here
still taking pride in his name and
representing his name
and and that was was powerful to me
very very powerful too because when
you're in there i i
you know i'm sure speaking to my dad
like you know you start losing the will
to [__]
live and carry on and if you've got if
you've got a son out there who's taken
over the world it
it's a it's a huge array of hope and
light to keep him going so that must
have helped him
tremendously yeah he told me he told me
that big time
and and i loved being able to do that
for him
even though that was pretty much the
only thing that i could do at that point
i loved that was it the covington fight
was was that the first offense yeah
yeah yes that that for me was
one of the best ufc fights of all time
if not the
best easily the best welterweight fight
of all time
and you know as much as he's a dick i
gotta give credit covington
is a part of the reason for that i
actually think
uh and i've been criticized for saying
this i think prime covington beats prime
jsp
i think he's he is a very very good
fighter so the fact that you were able
to
to beat him in the way you did uh just
is
a huge testament to what you've achieved
but
what i loved about the fight was um
there was no feeling out period
it was immediate like we want to hurt
each other [__] it was personal
and when you've you know part of a
legacy
is having great rivals and and people
who you know there would be no mcgregor
without jose aldo
that you know and it's important to have
them people and he brought
the the best out in you and and you
brought it big time
what was it like being in the middle of
that when for the first time
you know you're not you're not going
through the guy like a hot knife through
butter and there's a real level of
resistance here
and he's putting up a hell of a fight um
it's one of those things that that's
what makes
you um that that's really what how you
when you say you battle tested
that's what that means and that's really
how you know mano imano that's what mano
a model means
when you both take each other's best
shot and you're able to still be in
there
and being able to rise to it it's a
different level it's a different
psychological level that you go to
knowing that i can go through this and
this guy is
the best next best guy out there but i
was able to go through this guy
and still accomplish what i set out to
do
different level of it puts you in a
different mental state
and um yeah that's why there was no
feeling now
i we had to hurt each other and and
there was so much pressure on me because
just
how much of a dick he was but people
hated him so they were hoping you'd take
us out of
the world the word the pressure with the
world of the world was
on me the world needed me to and there
was no other way
for me to go out if i hadn't went out
there and took him down and just you
know won the decision the world wouldn't
have been satisfied
the world wanted it to end the way it
did by me break
in his face and stopping him because he
said some [__] up [__] to you about
about
was it your family and all sorts of
stuff yeah he said a lot of things he
you know about my family he talked about
my my former manager
uh who passed away you know um
things about you know my team my just
everything
he did whatever he could to
try to get me out of who i am as a
fighter
and you know there's there's
me i think i'm i'm almost i'm most
dangerous when i'm able to think because
like i said i'm a problem solver
so if i'm able to think through things i
find the solution
and now when you put someone in a state
where they're not
thinking they're just reacting it's very
easy to make a mistake
and he did everything possible to try to
put me in that in that place
but even in that place i'm a dangerous
very dangerous individual and that's
what i needed him to understand so
that's why there was no feeling out
process
we were we were we had to scrap right
away and
we definitely did you were the calm in
the chaos man
and uh and he wasn't able to do to you
what he did everyone else but he did
robbie lawler which is he brings the
chaos and and
it's too much for people it's too the
tempo or the pace that you put some
people but
you know you are really able to keep up
and and
and push as well which you know
considering the way you're built
i you know you would think you were a
bit more
lean towards the power but you pushed it
with him
and um what were there moments of doubt
for the first time that crept in there
or were you quite
did you question yourself at all or
maybe more so than you ever had done
before
i i wouldn't say i questioned myself it
was i started to
question the rounds because um um
the one thing about me and that i think
i started doing early on
and even in right wrestling careers
i always wanted to be in control
and so i always knew what the score i
never looked at the scoreboard i always
knew what the score was when i was
wrestling i always knew
because i was in complete control i
trained to be
in complete control i everything that i
do is so i'm in control
so i'm controlling the outcome and i've
always been able to do that
even in my fights with tyron woodley i
knew
every round i won that round i won that
round
i won that round so for the first time
in my career
i'm like wow there was a lot of it was
back and forth that round
which way are the judges leaning i was
thinking that but at no
point in my head did i think i'm gonna
lose
or did i think i wasn't going to finish
him
at no point in my mind did that change
coming into the fifth it was like each
and every round i started to smile more
and more because
now he was starting to understand what
i've been saying for a long time
is that hey i'm a different animal
than all these other guys so he was
starting to understand it to where
as the rounds progressed my smile got
bigger his got smaller
yeah and and and i think that that
was the difference is yes i i questioned
some of the rounds but at no point did i
question whether i would win the fight
or not by by round five
he's used to people being considerably
deflated and
annoying they've already lost and that
this as much as it was a little
different for you was a lot different
for him
um what did it feel like when you
eventually just landed that shot and
knew
this is the moment i'm putting him away
i that that what i do remember is
marching and it was just like action
reaction he threw a punch
i saw it slipped back and i threw it
right down the middle
beam hit him in the face he drops
the crowd he rubs and it was like
my energy level just got refilled
you know times 10. after that moment i
could have gone and another five rounds
wow i had such a surge of energy
to finish this guy it was
i that's all i remember is just like i
was like wow i'm not even
tired at all and i've been i was hit the
most ever because
i didn't care at that point i didn't
care i didn't i just
wanted to fight it was so personal
that um i just wanted to fight i didn't
care about getting hit i didn't care
that i wasn't
protecting myself in certain places i
just wanted to hurt him
and when i landed that shot it was such
a surge of energy
that anything that he had done before
was
meant nothing this right here i just got
it
another five rounds and need to go if we
had to go all night i was gonna be here
all night
and that's what i remember about that
moment dana recently
announced that he is your next opponent
um how do you feel about that
well i mean they say that all the time
that's that's dana's job
that's that might be the next opponent
that he wants you know but
now we're kind of in a position to where
it's not just oh yeah that's what's
gonna happen
you know we're business partners now i
hear you yeah i absolutely
respect dana and and his opinion and
that's why what makes for good business
is he has he has his thoughts i have my
thoughts
we bring it together we make a deal and
and things move forward
and that's how it works now and so um
honestly that's the one thing about me
is i've never shied away from
anyone anyone at any time
it doesn't matter i am at a different
level
and in order for me to continue to let
people know that i'll take on
anyone and so yeah um
if that happens to be the next fight
then you know of course
i welcome it i think everyone would want
to see that again
um i don't know it might be a little
different this time might be a lot
quicker
but you know i think we've improved
since then and i don't think he has to
be honest with you
and that's that's the beauty of it yeah
for people
for him to say expect the same guy
you know it's a little crazy but you
know that's it is what it is and i think
that would be the beauty of it if that
fight happens again
you know there's a lot of big things
happening there's a lot of big fights uh
leon edwards is fighting
you know nate diaz leon everest is a guy
that has been
putting on an impressive win streak in
the division you know hasn't lost a
fight since he lost to me
in 2015. and so that that's that's
impressive in its own you know he
could be deserving of it depending on
how he yeah what kind of noise he goes
and makes
i feel sorry for leon because he just
ain't in his personality to make much
noise like
i watch his interviews and god bless him
like he clearly has skills
but his interviews are as they're born
dry you know what i mean so
it's it's difficult to sell the guy who
um
you know he's my countryman so i root
for him but i
if you're gonna try and draw money with
this guy i'll call colby it's an easy
choice i guess
yeah for that entertainment aspect if it
was if it was up to dana white obviously
that's why he would say colby
absolutely so i understand that aspect
of it
you know there's a lot of things that
need to be talked about but absolutely i
don't
i don't shy away from anybody i'll beat
up anybody
[Laughter]
um yeah and your fans love you for that
and i think that's what made me warm to
you a lot more is as i was getting
disenchanted
with fighters taking so much time off
there was this guy just grinding away
and beating everyone who's put in front
of him and and
you aside from khabib i feel like we've
lacked some dominant champions you know
as anderson and jsp
um you know retired obviously um
izzy izzy is becoming that at
middleweight as well but you know
um i appreciate that you will take on
all comers and even
getting on to the next fight you had and
i hope i'm not i've just realized we've
been talking three hours bro
i i won't take much longer i promise i
feel like uh
i've just sort of taken your whole day
off sorry but um
gilbert burns like how was it going
against the guy who you
loved and cared about and even going
back to your fight ideas when i was
re-watching it
there he is cheering you on and i'm like
whoa like
this god yeah like
that one was it was tough um well they
say oh it's just business it's just
business that one was
one of the most personal one for
personal one for me
because what's more personal than a guy
who knows
the time that you put in a guy that you
shared
meals with a guy that you've held his
kids
jesus what's more more personal than
that a guy that you've helped
pursue his dreams and his aspiration of
being the lightweight champion of the
world
and now he's coming to your division and
says i'm gonna take it from you i know i
can take it from you
because all those times when you helped
me
i was measuring you up i was sizing you
up
so i know i can take it from you to
where
in my mind you feel betrayed you know
little sense yeah because in my mind i
was helping you
some of those times i was being light on
you
so you would get to build up the
confidence to be able to go out and do
your thing
i was doing everything a great partner
and a great teammate
should do for their friend and that's
helped them i flew all the way to brazil
to help you
the coordinates give you advice on a
fight and
when that i saw that and i felt that i
felt betrayed and
that hurt a lot because you don't get on
a flight for a guy
unless there's real brotherly love there
yeah
and and um initially it did
because of the way he was trying to
build the fight and i understand it's a
fight business
but initially it kind of rubbed me the
wrong way because it's like
really that's how you felt all along all
these years that's how you felt
and then i just i had to put it put it
beside me it's like okay
that's i i gotta show you i gotta teach
you a lesson now
and i watched that fight back
over and even in the beginning of the
fight
they bring us together and they announce
it and at that point i was a different
person when i cross into the cage
i'm no longer kamara ooshman the dad
who's silly with his daughter
i am the nigerian nightmare and once i
was already there
the nigerian nightmare already has a
plan and
a mode and a place that has put you and
he was in that place
so we come to the center and he reaches
his hands to touch gloves and i wasn't
having none of it
i wasn't having it and um do you have a
look in your eyes as well that other
fighters don't get
you get this like death stare on you you
know what i'm talking about
i wouldn't say it's a death stare it's
um if the fighters aren't able to look
through that look
it's the look of you understanding that
for me i look at you as do you
understand what's about to happen
yeah if you understand that that we're
both i'm
coming to push you to the point of death
in here if you're not prepared for that
then you might as well just give up now
make it easy on yourself
when he caught you early on that that
was the thing that made me go oh
[__] kamaru uzman is here to stay
because that was a hell of a shot and
the composure that you showed
you kept your hands up you didn't back
off you didn't show you know
like i thought what the [__] is it going
to take to beat this guy
if he can stay in the fire
as that's happening and not even show
anything it was impressive that me
thank you i i um and that was one of the
things too
is is that exactly what i just described
you you landed the good one but you
didn't kill me
so i told you you got to kill me if you
not if you didn't come here to kill me
it's going to be a long night and i just
stay with mike
started chipping away and chipping away
and chipping away that he realized
i think towards the end of the first
round after that he realized
wow okay there was a smile
i remember there was a smile between you
at the end of the first
but then you turned the tables on him
with that jab
and at the end of the second there was
no smile from him
he realized then oh [__] i'm in a
[__] real
i'm in a problem yeah big time he knew
that you were serious yeah
yeah that's what i like i said it in the
first it's that's what fighting is such
an intimate moment because we can feel
each other's souls in there
and and and i'm feeling his soul and his
his spirit
and he feels mine and i'm starting to
we're tugging on each other's spirit and
i'm starting to break his a little bit
and and he knows that mine's growing and
we look at each other in the first
and he looks at me wouldn't speak
but his he told me in his eyes he told
me
he said i didn't land that good shot
yeah and i said yes you did you
definitely did but
you know what's about to happen right
now right and he looks at me and he goes
yeah i know you're about to beat this
[__] up i know
and we just our eyes we didn't speak but
our eyes just
talked to each other and then the second
he knew what was happening
i just started chipping away and
chipping away
and and that was it towards the end of
the second there was no smile because he
knew he's like [__]
you really are beating the [__] out of
me and i said yeah i told you
i told you it was going to happen and
you were emotional at the end of that
fight too but i think for
for very for different reasons what were
you feeling when you were crying there
and it was just so
powerful it was a it was a rollercoaster
because
i had put myself like the same way
my daughter can turn the switch off i
put myself there i was a
nigerian nightmare in there got to
finish boom
finished him and then i'm blacked out
you get to this moment to where you
black out with adrenaline i'm just
there and i'm i'm you know i'm
screaming something and then i hear him
crying and then it just like
flipped the switch off like kamarusman
that's your friend wow you helped him
you flew all the way to brazil
to help this guy win a fight so he could
provide for his kids who you've held
and his wife and it was like a ton of
bricks hit me in the chest like
bro and i just i couldn't hold it
oh no oh yeah
you're an empathetic person you've got a
lot of empathy in you for a fighter
you know you really can't put yourself
in other people's shoes
it's weird it is it's very weird because
um
and i think that's the crazy thing about
it i can turn it on and off
um so i choose which i
like normally watching the fight like
the fights tonight i'm
i watch and i cringe like how do these
guys kick each other
i cringe at fights i go to the ufc event
and i can hear the kicks because i'm
front row and i could
like how do these guys do this i cringe
at it
but then i do it and everyone's like
well you do that too like
ah i don't think about it like that
because i can turn it off
and go out there and do it so when you
screamed at the camera
taking what from who was like
like i'm sitting watching at home like
i'm not taking nothing from you but
like it was like it was one of sometimes
when fighters win and they maintain that
aggression and i'm remembering things
like
brock lesnar at ufc 100 where he screams
at the cage and that like
when you maintain that you you know this
person isn't planning
this isn't the top of the mountain for
them and and that's what really
impressed me about that i was like
we're looking at a long title ring here
this just by your reaction i knew that
you're not going to give this up
easily this is going to be a long
process that people are going to have to
watch
and and you really cemented that when
you
knocked out mars vidal because a lot of
people were predicting a very similar
fight
and that was when i was like you're
better than jsp
like for me that was the moment that
when you knocked out mozville i'm like
i love jsp you know he was but when you
look at some of the fights he had and
how close some of them were and how
you know yadda yadda we insane jsp do
that to jorge mas vidal
not not devastating like that not sweat
like flying at the rose head from his
head being caved in
by like a shot like that i i'm not
saying jsp can't strike but you showed
just another level in that and
that was such a statement and i hope you
know that
i am i mean thank you thank you so much
for that i um
it was it's just a chip it's a chip on
my shoulder that i still
carry and i think um
it's gonna be a point where i'm gonna
eventually just say um
i need to put this down just learning
from
all my mentors all the people that i
look up to that have done this
okay guys like daniel cormier guys like
eddie alvarez
guys like rashad evans and and
having them talk to me about this and
and
how they get away from it even my
jiu-jitsu coach george
santiago you know a lot of people
real mma fans know who george santiago
is george santiago is
in um probably it's in the top five they
just ranked them top
five uh i think it was a welterweight
fight maybe middleweight once we're in a
middleweight fight
of all time top five when he fought
sakuraba
in japan i mean i watched that fight i'm
like
how is this possible these two guys
tried to
literally try to kill each other for
five rounds
yeah every strike was to kill
nothing was set up every strike was to
kill each other
and and for him to go through that it
takes something from you going through
battles like that
and i'm fully aware that i have that
chip
right now and there's gonna come a time
where i'm gonna say um
yeah i need to put this down because
it's not healthy to
walk around with this thing for that
long
and i think georgetown pierre recognized
it yeah
that's why he walked away i think george
was a little opportunistic though when
he came back like cherry picked bisping
i'm like
i don't like that you avoided anderson
for dear life for the longest time
and now bisping's the charm and you're
like ah go on then i'll go to
middleweight i'm like
this is not this is not chum champ
for me this is not the same thing no
don't get me wrong bisping
god i love him he's my hero but he was
towards the end of his career
he he could afford anderson in his prime
any time he wanted
you know it didn't happen for a good
reason no absolutely no i i understand
that i and
i get that you know for sure you know he
he definitely picked i mean and even
whitaker was a champion before he could
have came back from whatever yeah he
didn't fancy that either did he
yeah for the younger stronger hungrier
you know an aggressive guy come back for
you either bro let's be real because
he doesn't want to come back he knows
the new school overthrows the old school
he's he's he's talked about khabib he's
talking about bisping he's talk
but he doesn't want the guy who has his
crown right now
that should tell a lot of the people who
are blinded by their love for george
and i am not taking away from him but he
knows
he's smart yeah no i know the chip that
you have on your shoulder
that's something he doesn't have he
isn't the guy to stay in the fire when
the fires come
like the last fight he had if you watch
that you say exactly why
he in his prime he'd never [__] with you
and that people are going to hate me i
don't give a [__] i'm saying it
you know you know you're right and i'm i
respect you
i i truly respect yours you know and um
i just think he let's be honest he
understands it's a different
but he's in that position and a part of
that respect is him
is respecting the fact that he is in
that position to where he could
cherry pick yeah he painted them back
and he yeah yeah
he's like why would i go back and fight
the the hungrier guys that are dangerous
that
could could definitely hurt me why when
i could take this safe guy
still make the money and i'm still there
my legacy
it's the same reason floyd isn't coming
back for a canelo alvarez very much like
exactly it's cool like i'm i'm not
disrespecting floyd for not wanting
canelo i get it
but there's people out there who will
just they want to put
la la la la la they don't want to accept
reality yeah
and i'm just looking at you like let's
appreciate this guy while he's here and
let's not do what we've done so often
and regret it and the more i watch you
the more i do appreciate you and i
appreciate your time it's three and a
quarter hours now i've got a few
questions left i promise we're going to
finish this because
this is going to be my longest podcast
ever and i didn't expect that so
um jorge mars vidal knocked clean out
shocked the world to be honest with you
because the hype train was incredible
and well deserved for jorge
and you're there and you finally get to
put
the belt around your dad's waist he's
out of prison
it's emotional you get to make him the
champion of the of your world
essentially what was it like mate
there's there's very few moments free
surreal moments that that you
go through in life that you're like is
this really happening yeah
and um for me i took a philosophy class
in
college and uh the philosophy one of the
biggest topics of that
that class was the pursuit of happiness
what we classify as the pursuit of
happiness and
for me the pursuit of happiness have
always been
moments certain moments in life that you
can never
buy that you can never replicate
and that's um i think it's for a child
it's it's the moment to make your
parents smile uncontrollably
and fill their hearts with joy to where
they can you can never
buy that no matter how much money you
have you can't buy them
you can't replicate that moment to be
able to fill their heart
up with so much joy i think that's one
of the moments another moment would be
for that to be the parent and have your
child
do that for you feel your heart up with
joy because they
listen to you they have followed the
path and the lessons that you've taught
and they've become successful and
that was one of those moments for me to
be able to do that
for my parents it was like surreal like
holy [__]
i was able i was alive to be able to
witness it's
something that most people never do i
was alive to be able to witness this
and and that was how powerful that
moment is for me
you know that's definitely up there that
moment and the moment of me speaking
with my daughter in the cage those are
the two moments that
i would say i will remember
forever i love that mate and it was a
beautiful thing to watch uh
i um i've got two more questions our
first one is
if the movie is made which there really
should be
you you know in movies there's like a
there's like a halfway point there's
that there's that moment where
the switch flicks in the fighter or the
star's
mind and you and you know now now
i'm going to become the person i always
want i always should have
become what moment would that be
in your life so far when you look back
at it to be honest i don't know i don't
know if i've come to that yet
um i don't know um
and people say this too when they're
everyone's like oh don't
don't you see all these records don't
you consider yourself the greatest
no i don't dwell on that i don't worry
about that
okay i think when and you get to a
certain point in life where
things have been done things and you you
sit back and say wow
i did that at that moment and and
you know i don't i don't think i'm at
that moment yet i think
time has to go by to where i can be like
oh
i think that point is where i think i'm
just still young enough to where
i'm not and my mind is still so in the
fire enough to where i don't
i don't think about it yet because
you're a serial achiever as well like
like we've said earlier like
it's never you know it's never time to
smell the roses when you
you you're like you you know but um but
on that
my final question is how would you like
to be remembered
i've thought about this one a lot this
is
this is a big one and i think this is
probably one of the most important
questions for me
um and this is
part of what was the knock on me you
know my careers
oh why doesn't he brag and talk trash
why isn't he like corner why does he try
to sell us why isn't he this
being honest you know connor's gotten
you know
the fame that he's got rightfully so
he's done what he's done
but there are certain things that conor
has done that conor will say
oh i regret saying that for that fight i
regret
saying this about this guy i regret
coming at him and his family and his
religion like that
that's what i don't want to be
and and just quick example is
um when i i started when i was training
for the olympics i had an
opportunity i could have signed with a
big wrestling club to kind of sponsor me
while i was training but um there was
this new club
um that was from the colorado the new it
was a
kids club they wanted a senior level
athlete training for the olympics
so they were going to raise fundraise
and and helped me
support me in traveling and training so
i could just train
and this was a christian a family was a
husband and wife and four kids and they
started the club because one of their
kids
passed away in a tragic accident
and so this the club was all in the
kid's state
remembering this kid and so they it was
a kid's club a bunch of kids all
christian kids christian families and i
these kids
look up i was there they i was like that
guy for them i was a senior level
olympic level athlete and these kids
were in
primary school wrestling yeah and so
watching those kids grow up i couldn't i
can't
just say i don't care how those kids
see me or how those kids see the example
that i set
i can't look those kids come and train
and teach those kids
when i'm on on you know on a promo
saying oh [__] this guy's religion
family i don't care i'm gonna kill this
guy i'm gonna do this i'm gonna
i can't look myself in the mirror and
say that
i can't look at my daughter in the face
and say that and then
promote a fight go out there and finish
the fight and then come home and my
daughter watches that later and my
daughter goes hey daddy why did you say
that
and i'm like oh i was just pretending
for the camera
i couldn't be that guy and i think that
was one of the biggest
you want to be i'm real because i
understand that with the great power
that i have right now where people are
listening and paying attention to me
there's also great responsibility with
that yeah
and part of that responsibility is
making sure that i show my daughter
the real me so she can come home and say
oh that's
she sees me on tv and says oh that's my
daddy and how i'm acting on tv oh yeah
that's my dad and then i come home yeah
that's still my dad
as opposed to who was that guy on
television
and you're not that guy that's not how
you act at home
i think that's the most important thing
to you authenticity is a big thing for
you
and i like yes i think that's why people
are warming over time now is because
yeah you haven't gone out there
to be mr sherman but you you are the
real guy and
i think over time as well like
one inevitably if when a fighter has
passed their prime
they will have to look back and and and
look at what they achieved and
it's no good flashing your rolexes are
nothing like a [__] when you've then
lost three in a row or whatever
mcgregor has lost for example as the
example is
and i think if if you do have that you
know
um moment in your career people will
treat you differently because of how you
acted
while you're a dominant champion they
will give you more respect
because of that you know rather than
wanting to rub it in your face
because you haven't conducted yourself
in that way
absolutely absolutely and my dad used to
always say uh
everybody loves to chair but while
they're cheering they can't wait to boo
and and that's that's exactly what conor
f and i know it's
it's tough i know it's hard being car i
know it's hard
i'm a champion and i know how hard it is
to be a champion now i can't imagine
what connor is going to do
that's got to be hard you can't do
anything anything
people can't wait to boo because now
people are just waiting to rub it in
your face yes of course you've got the
money you've got all this you've got all
that but bro you got knocked out your
last fight
and then you won for like four in your
last you know four or five fights or
something like that you know
people just can't wait to throw that in
your face so yeah
it's um it's a tough life to lead you
know but
authenticity is very very uh important
to me kamaru i'm
so grateful for your time i mean i i i
told your manager we'd be an hour it's
three and a half this is ridiculous but
you've not complained once you've not
you're an absolute gentleman
and um i'll always be a fan um
ladies and gentlemen the greatest
fighter in the world in my opinion
genuinely and judging by the ufc
uh championship that he's got is it's a
fact
and um honestly uh you've got a youtube
channel now as well
uh people should follow that i'll put
the link in the description below
if you want to follow all of the
training camps that kamaru is doing
and of course following social media
this guy is
a true champion cheers come on thank you
thank you i appreciate it
appreciate your time as well thank you